I'm on put that away okay good that was
close we only showed some real
paraphernalia all right well welcome
everybody to the rematch just calm
versus chest bras I'm pretending like
I'm hosting the show I guess cuz I'm the
guy here with the producer but fun fact
I know as little if not less than
everybody else here about what we're
gonna do today so I gotta give a huge
shout-out to the chat though guys hey
guess what apparently you guys are
pretty popular there's been a lot of
just brought emotes here are you guys
you guys ready to defend your crown I
think Oh Danny Danny this is the the
pregame for me tonight where you after
this no just me and then we'll find our
way outside but I got a I got a I got a
movie a den flicks movie and and a nice
glass of bubbly waiting for me at home I
think we might go real real heavy today
watch Rookie of the Year a Canadian
understands there was a baseball movie
that's huge I'm on like I mean you your
American boots are growing roots that's
that's what Susie is not Jonathan Taylor
Thomas the other guy with three first
names what's the matter oh I don't know
well so legit if you missed the article
I'm gonna grab the link and share which
would shed because I have the ability to
do said things but if you missed the
article there really is a crazy format
ahead today that none of us really know
what's gonna happen we've been told it
will be a grand mix of variants
different time controls and pg-13
behavior by all parties involved we've
we've got a lot on the line here not
just the pride and the prize fun photo
but just calm that's 500 bucks cash
right basically enough to pay for
whatever shenanigan
Erik's gonna get into tonight but also
we've got a big announcement in regards
to from now on these team chess battles
that we're trying to make a regular
habit they're gonna involve charities so
I'm gonna say thank you that the
subscribers coming in we just had a
massive gifted sub bomb coming in
awesome thank you but I'm gonna throw it
to our producer here and let him
describe the two charities that are
gonna be on today oh there he is hey
don't take it away all righty here we go
so yeah they can hear me jeez Danny you
think I don't know what I'm doing all
right so the first one the chest bras
are going to be raising money for is
right to play writes a play believes
that different types of play give
children the opportunity to learn
different things inside the classroom
games help children to actively engage
in their lessons enhancing their
learning outside of the classroom they
play through performance music or dance
to gain critical life skills writes a
play produces provides support to 15
countries around the world ensuring
children stay in school and find
empowerment through play their website
WWE to play USA org that was actually
more influenced by here but yes a nice
organization funded by the Norwegian
Olympic gold-medalist so they use a lot
of like they use a lot of sports
activities in chess as a way of you know
this fantastic okay cool
that's good for good for the rowdy ones
all right go for it
so the charity that Robert and Danny
will be competing for is adopt
a native elder the adopted native elder
program supports the traditional elders
who live in the cultural and spiritual
traditions of the Navajo people most
live in remote portions of the Navajo
reservation the program provides food
simple medicines clothing fabric and
yarns to help these elders live on the
land and their traditional lifestyle as
they have become elderly it has become
more more difficult for them to support
themselves on the land in their
traditional ways the organization sports
500 traditional elders who live in the
northern portion of Arizona and southern
Utah their website WN elder org alright
Danny take a bit so the the adopted
elder it was not that it's not an
amazing charity and when we beat you
guys we will be happily donating okay
but it was chosen in time for us to
announce a new show that will be coming
very soon to a twitch s theater near you
[Laughter]
I'm so confused I'm at a loss I you know
I think we chose a great man we have to
play serious testing but your queen on
each one get mad
we do with charity or I'm sorry about
the laughing there will be coming so the
adopted Danny show is coming your way
soon and in honor of the show that's
coming which we will announce that has a
format where a different Grandmaster
will have a certain amount of time to
adopt me in different time controls they
will be limited in their in their amount
of time like a running down clock like
the speech Chess Championship but
they'll have a sermon a time to adopt me
and if we win today we're gonna adopt a
native elder in honor of that new show
and Robert's very excited about it I am
as well I I'm sorry they got out of
control but we're back okay and I'm
doing great
i I'm just excited that the charities
are becoming a part of the show because
it's encouraging gifted subs as we see
there you know that the crying I mean
good theater Danny you've got some gifts
up there well sometimes you lose it that
hasn't happened since I blew myself on
Brook endings just championships you
remember that ons Oran you remember that
no it's like 8:00 p.m. yeah this is like
a bit of an evening show fuel and fun
start again shout out to all the stuffs
coming up we appreciate it I have I have
really hopefully set the tone of what
kind of show this is gonna be remember
all your bits and donations go directly
they split between the prize fund and
the charities that's what we're doing
today and
talking about Robert you want to bring
this crowd back into sanity what do you
think I don't even know what the format
is okay so here we go so now we have our
first piece of information from staff we
will play a 5/5 blitz game to start it
will be straight-up time controls and it
will determine who gets white so it's
it's a lot like the last match where we
had a blitz game to start to determine
who gets white what you get on a plane
oh my god we just got 5,000 bits I don't
even know how much money that is but
it's a lot of bits yeah there was ten
gifted subs and then there was 5,000
bits but yours 5,000 pennies they're
approximately the same they're 50 yes
you get you a bottle of maple syrup
that's how long ago it's being they
don't have pennies anymore so you're due
for a visit that's not even true I was
in Ottawa and - yeah you're right
actually
[Laughter]
all right well all I know is yeah well
we'll check on donations and
notifications so we're already getting
lots of love thank you for that we will
we will obviously gather and tabulate
everything but what is that noise I
thought that was like an adoption taking
place live I am girl from Turkey nope I
thought that was a very small all right
let's do it
Robert are you ready yes I don't know
I'm ready for but I'm ready
we are gonna crush the chest bras this
time I mean it we will separate the
audio team chest so to start Robert why
don't white what we're going to do a
four a d4 oh the games started let's you
know you you know
for better support all right go ahead
you realize the game is started
yep it's on them now their move hey
Danny how you feeling I'm great can the
people hear us I hear them it's their
move so right now they can't hear us so
he's in control orange a good show we
got another donation thank you so much
so it's their move they're talking but
you and I get to sit here and talk bad
about them all day while they're kind of
dark in so the people hear us this is
amazing good that's what the people
wanna hear by the way I got this mug out
just for you buddy cuz you're one of my
best friends I love you
what does he say I love my computer all
my friends awesome that's so cute
Danny you're sweetheart hey we just got
1500 from this is gonna be nuts I
don't even know how it and why it's
gonna have but it's gonna be nuts do
they know it's their move yeah they do I
think you're trying to be rude and give
us time odds my guess they do for their
crowd but guess what no one can hear you
guys so joke's on you Canada Canada is
above us where they belong as a head
protective advice device that's all but
that's all that came it was good for us
to be America's hat
you mean helmet that's what a protective
device is a helmet before taking the
time disadvantage what what you want to
play here I think we play yeah he can't
make moves on this board
do you want to login I literally can't
make a move I don't know why
like I just can't okay okay I've never
had this before I'll try to log into me
here I have this yeah why didn't you
guys move yet I can't move
someone's mess-up Aman's
the county has three stop
conspiracy you can tell because no you
can't move at all I can't I can't move
a great moment where Danny couldn't
remember the word Helmut he calls it a
protective cap at some point we're gonna
figure out what's going on everybody
okay jsw three four five just don't need
a hundred bucks
what whoa thank you Dad W I don't even
know what we're doing right now
me neither I'm very confused
we literally have had a game aborted and
made a few awkward jokes at Canada's
expense and we've had like $300 donated
like nobody would do anything yet making
fun Canada's apparently that's where
that's where the money is that's where
the money is
I'll try moving now we'll see if you
guys are you know messed up my computer
but alright let's stay on the call while
we figure it out you can did you login
okay yeah okay so let me login somewhere
else so I can okay separate us now I
love you guys what are we gonna do here
okay remember last time we played pretty
quickly and did good Sicilian let's do
it let's do they're gonna play Ross Lima
against us watch now guess who's here
with me Bobby yes he knows his theory
that's just that's actually yeah let's
do it pre move Knight takes d4 I faith
yes sir yes sir yes sir yes one did she
do it all well exactly is that we
exactly exactly Jen
at least see the twitch okay so you want
to get a stick so you wanna go 96 I feel
like trying something different for
myself but that's one 896 okay yeah
that's what my idea is our tune to play
96 have you played an icy 16 sorry 96
and 1 and a 6 ok eight-six right now no
I'm also okay to try that it's all in
the same yeah in realm
it's a tempo down potentially on when
people just take on c6 but yeah it it
gives us in blitz an easy structure like
oh they didn't they didn't go for it
okay oh you were actually playing you
were playing so you didn't see it but I
had a great position you crushed Derek
again
arena Kings is the over yet cuz he
doesn't get over he licks his wounds for
like years okay so we're just gonna play
quickly here let's do it let's keep
going we know exactly what we're up to
we know we're doing the English attack
we're going for a straight forward
approach we're gonna castle long and do
exactly what we do them the other time
in the tomorrow Sicilian that's how
babies are made in the time oh no
Sicilian it's a fun all right so now now
we capital the castle on the clock so
we're doing it amazingly well yep is it
they don't realize that though we've
come with no knowledge of the format we
had to read the article two minutes
before if you're just getting here we
have no idea what's going on but we're
playing chess I you know it's funny but
yeah I was in a story with Bobby we're
on a car you wanna buy yeah yeah sirs
crazy house videos were really good I
love the way he moves the piece
yeah there's five Danny Danny likes to
play the English attack that's right I
yeah I like the idea of h5 it's a normal
play it here or do you play like b5
it's normal here to take on the form
play b5 that's a really salt but you
want to try you try sure okay I like it
like the look you don't normally Castle
it would you just tilt knowing yeah you
chill thinking play b5 without taking
maybe yeah correct exactly Bishop be
savvy artsy 895 yeah yeah tell me don't
do it okay wait King be ones find I'd be
threes fine thinking you 180 IQ okay
there's logic oh I think we just got to
play fast all right
cool sounds good okay so there's a
couple ideas here one is Knight takes c6
and you relocate the night around 2 e 2
and d4 and it's kind of a simple way to
approach it you can also take c6 if they
take with the Queen you have b5 they
take the pot okay on there's also Bishop
d3
[Music]
several things are fine here I mean
honestly I typically look to do
something
with the knight on d4 here whether it's
night back to b3
robbery good night b3 the go d6 right
yeah 93 d6 with h5u transition usually
to the f4 f5 flam right and you can do
that with the bishop going to d3 here
even though it seems a little awkward
but white just light plays 93 Bishop b3
f4 like you can play for h3 in chief or
as well you go select Queen up to at
some point
yeah yeah sue 93 we're down the clock
and they're asking me if I trust you're
opening theory I trust in that's right
- I'm play Bishop e7 first or 95 first
here this should be siphoned out worried
about 95 right yeah that's what I said I
I think that either d6 or 95 - to stop
that 95 is more flexible okay yeah
sometimes we can play d4 and d5 I want
to go on Bishop d7 next procedure
you
yeah you know I like what we have so far
mm-hmm
so Billy Bishop e7 you think he's trying
to go Bishop e6 in 95 for something yes
d6 is still playable right it should be
six Queen ba
yeah and you want to do that or like
Bishop e7 maybe I don't know if it's a
better be for native or maybe if you
want to just start with g6 yeah let's
all let's let them I mean yeah it's
Danny you got a we got a lot Danny just
do some day anything do anything for
sure there's 4 H 3 seem sense I feel
like it's the easier move and we don't
need to go for that yet yeah you're
right I don't know that I don't know
that I'm right but I think that there's
no reason to yet because
at 4 to 5 I was always putting my
mom v6 and give him the opportunity yeah
this should be 695 thank you to all the
bits and donations coming in don't even
know what to say you guys are amazing
um okay now that 494 takes Beauty tags
and I see one they have to be filed we
don't have Bishop e6 anymore um one idea
in these lines is Bishop a7 and then
after rook b7 the bishop goes to d4 in
some positions but I don't think we gain
anything there well then before it's not
really easily playable because then a6
will be hanging the very least that's
true you can also play f4 dicey for
anyone yeah minute there's before in the
mornings yeah but there are some lines
of the bishops on is there any the rook
is on b7 we have like Bishop takes they
go be for you like Bishop takes c4
Knight a5 ideas as well but you have to
sort of time that well yeah it's on a5
pride what do they try to play for g4
all right what are we so but what idea
do that again is just Bishop b3 like it
sounds weird but like they're gonna I'm
with you I'm with let's do it and don't
forget that we're threatening g4 now now
there was also the option of now Bishop
d7 beautiful I was considering because
now there's like no need for we continue
just go like you know rebel we go but
like if we play d4 here that nice going
to e to I think probably not hateful you
don't think a for well is just wondering
about Bishop d7 96 Bishop b5 and the
knights get little awkward but maybe
okay let's call them out it's just so be
for Nettie for Bishop d7 at b6 this
should be five and say the Knights
awkward all right I guess yeah I can buy
that because you have f4 we can take on
d3 and then the bishop on b5 does a good
deal I was very strong yeah yeah cuz cuz
rook rook can't one we meant by visually
z4 okay well then then yes then let's go
feed for to go a5 even yeah yeah we can
just
I think then crush that down the board
ready yeah let's go let's go okay
it's a 494 or they Dixie 394 takes takes
Knight a5 is an issue or well we do have
to like actually keep in mind that they
might a for a 3s or something I just
don't get worried about in these lines
cuz like the Knights on e to the bishop
worries me that you're not worried well
you know right wait wait
UCF for like kind of like f4 yeah F for
Angie for are both possible now the only
thing that nice about g4 is like then
f-words even stronger but the thing is G
for a for where we're putting our Knight
to write on c1 and then just hiding
there if a3 b3 our Bishopville and III
can go to d4 at a moment's notice I'm
not worried about getting made it on the
dark squares okay and I'm good with g4 f
for just choose baby code g4 do you
forget I'm a little worried about our
King but I agree with you and we are
gonna adopt so many older Native
Americans after this because we're gonna
win and we are getting so money donation
but we are gonna adopt so many elderly
Native Americans I feel uncomfortable
with the way we're discussing this we
could go we could go like night c4 we
could also
we could also take on d3 if night takes
maybe b3 and if pawn takes maybe b3 like
I want to take and play bishop on e6
maybe so the night jockey so what I'm
worried about is 93 CDs 53 it sounds so
bad there's an actual charity for
adopting them exactly helping them
keyword that's what we're doing you're
not beating them attention chess games
okay III with the which pawn so they're
fine
this is kind of a bluff like they don't
have it they're gonna take d3 and like
Bishop a6 what do they have so like me
tell you what the a pawn
no yeah like the C point yeah C pawn for
sure patio so let's take it if 93 and
the rook takes we always have a hanging
key yes if they take back with the well
they're gonna take back with the pawn
right but then we can do 93 that's what
you're saying that's my point yeah and
then over TV right so that's right do
you want to do that
yeah yeah and then you take back on g4
okay okay look you think this way so -
we'll grab the b3 I guess I mean and if
they attack our look where we put in the
rook uh easy all the way back okay I
guess we were forced 97
right or some bishop a six maybe it
should be six not easy to see one oh
yeah or even just takes f6 okay
[Music]
I think
we have to
if you go all the way back Rick see one
and then do we play like we can do rook
see one okay let's play quickly rook
rook see when he wants knight c6 do we
play a 95 or it's crazy
oh that's not ready to go if you take do
you wonder 95 or 95 maybe 95 is good
yeah that is fun 85 now we can play
Bishop f6 in case yes about 6 next right
yeah word that kind of depends maybe the
best defense sometimes will have maybe
with the c8 Bishop take it take it take
it take it right yep and then bring the
knight back to see one right oh wait
nobody's gonna Bishop f6 that was bad no
it's fine is it fine no I don't think it
is we now we have to play rook see one
way doesn't play think about mmm I was a
queen c2 but that also looks now how
crazy choose not bad but then the other
moves through the Queen away yeah but
then we can play 92 and if Bishop f6 we
have nice c3 blow ever they can start
with Queen and misro sticks
aha okay we got a funny decision fast
cuz that was a miscalculation please
okay we can 1092 and efficient of six
bishops see one so risky
oh let's go Knights see - and a fishery
of six Bishop c1 and when we can bring
our knight in to e 3 and C 4 eventually
relocated just just yeah just forgot to
pick one
it's like I'm not gonna be good the
weight of a bad position now I don't
think they're really threatening
Tomatoes we should see one yeah I don't
think that there's really a concrete
because we're gonna move the 93 and
unleash the Queen to defend B - okay so
do you like that idea
well I got four to play e5 though I'm
also coming do we wanna play e5 first or
takes then what
yeah I never follow up if f4 Bishop b2
Bishop takes Queen c3 we can move the
night there's no at four I got four
before okay they want to cut the bishop
maybe Bishop e7 for now it allows 47 but
painting the pond could be nice I don't
know how about we have 90 seconds okay
first uh-huh 93 and then Bishop needs
work
okay he's gonna make me sack but that's
fine uh-huh but his apocalypse
yeah yeah yeah okay
or maybe we can play Queen before so
Bishop basics I'm sorry you're fine
but we still have a piece of some
pressure work g1 is good they can detect
in then IIITs andar square if we have
Bishop d2 c3 that obviously the idea or
not next your uh Queen G well and then
they're gonna take our Evil Queen d2 to
protect arc we have three we have two oh
sorry each boy was falling though it's
not a bad but we have f5 do we want to
play it probably not because the fish
won't see it will get loose take age
five okay all right we have one well
given this Bishop a six so we got to be
careful about that
how about pawn or Bishop e3 Bishop e3
looks good
Fisher e3 good they're gonna move the
Queen and then we have to go ready for I
don't know but h5 s hanging as well so
that's to be okay okay yeah so they go
to a5 with the Queen ooh
whoa okay so just clean up oh there
Bishop d3 check coming we may have to
trade to save the queen take the Queen
and play e5 and the Tri provision of g6
yeah the game's heading away from us
here yeah we have somehow okay we have
an increment so let's try to
hey Brooke c1 I think let's just oh no
no that's bad
you should D should be sex yet and then
you can't go Bishop c3 yeah do that
yes his pieces are do we ever throw an H
for the fixed age because definitely
definitely soon when Tom what's right
now
sure just goes we have this objective f5
okay chief g5 also yeah check him
five maybe and we have G five to hold
upon and then wreckage for in case we
want to keep it sure and Ricky for also
um Rick what do you think of rook gee I
thought I was thinking of g5 and takes
h3 just direct but we can do other moves
like rookie 453 or roti a tricky 333
rook the rook to e3 take a tick on f4
yes might as well yeah Knight d5 um
maybe she bought g5 and king g6 okay
yeah it intersects and rook we should
probably you want to grab for Rick f3 we
can grab yeah because then we Commission
lunch 1 - you got a Shivaji - yeah rook
on v88 and rush the h-bomb yeah h3 yeah
yeah I like that we get thrown the towel
now yeah remember last time we won this
game and lost a match so maybe that
bodes well for our future
and after work if one okay they didn't
go work upon I was gonna resign for us
but it's over anyway but yeah alright
well resign okay so they get first what
do they get for winning this game yeah
they get colors they get colors that's
it remember last time we won this game
and lost the balls okay that was four
colors nice fortune for you because I
think a little huge cheer from Mike back
in just may just your 20,000 bits and my
reading your thing oh my she running for
the chest for us what she she betrayed
us okay but as they say in Canada
okay but okay okay see she said I'm
cheering for good chess see all right No
thank you just bass seriously thank you
and thank you to everybody alright well
they get colors but now here's the real
deal everybody and sorry to put on my PA
you know big chest voice on but that's
the truth I gotta tell somebody some
within here I don't know what game we're
playing next are you guys as nervous as
I am
we don't know what variant were in for
we have no idea what's coming up well
good good nervous you know before first
date yeah before your first kiss just
press away from this conversation yes
Bob yo Bob apparently all the way oh my
god we just don't need $100 JFW just
donate $100 are all right let's keep
somebody start the next game but I can't
take this how in God's name are we lower
rated than
[Laughter]
I asked that question earlier I was like
Danny why is there Eddie 22:38 the only
thing that I did was I while we were
waiting here I played some Blitzen
bullet so maybe my my whatever the
rating thing is less whatever that is we
may factor
Thanks HB 43 appreciate that $10
donation okay let's check the mode
Robert it is so this is just a regular
game 10 okay regular chess here we go
this is where the team chess this is
where we get these guys are we sure this
is regular chess I'm looking at the
squares okay we are in the eighth rank
we have the black pieces it's regular
chess okay exactly our time is taking
this we're coming for you another pawn
says it seems Eric at amount of a closer
match strategies and Danny and Robert
know what no way they don't understand
us Danny we have that game we had that
game yeah we if wouldn't I think we've
gone Brooksie one before
94 rooks even before g5 we haven't
crushed rook c1 before she thought yeah
g5 was a little premature it's okay we
were just getting into it you know we
know to coordinate all right what are we
doing here let's just play quickly
whatever you want well we have 15
minutes my mana goat I'm good with a 5
or c5
I'm trying to Ospina vanilla its king of
the hill Danny look I just look what the
game is
Oh maybe they don't know okay he's gotta
be 85 then no okay
one thing is takes Queen takes Knight c3
King D 7
but we can play d4 opportunity 7 correct
yes yes it still but yeah but yeah
that's that's fine that we can we can
probably take this and do that yeah okay
Queen 6593 King d7 d for mm-hmm yeah and
then yeah okay yeah okay by the way it's
also unclear if Gainey is aware there's
king of the hill but anyhow this is
definitely king of the hills
oh well I can suggest just normal theory
here by here Lucy bad there's also like
something simple like Bishop e5 chat
right I feel like
[Music]
I mean are there any lines where we go
like super deep those ones should
probably be good for thing seaport iris
crab you rule
I just message you we're on silent there
hey we love all of you we love these
people
we love every single every single person
people who just support chess are my
favorite people like am I allowed to
pick favorites allowed to pick favorites
when it comes to my kids I won't tell
you which one so now one of the ideas is
is we we just play traditional chess so
like nine of three is that the most
traditional like active way to play in
the Scandinavian I think we did called
JB right yeah
jump our thought where's the Finns when
you need them right yeah okay we can
take with the night or the or the Queen
and we're gonna be on a fine skin and
even now that they played night of three
perhaps Queen takes isn't a bad idea cuz
in the main theory with nice III Queen
a5g4 we get this you Chi for right and
we get those castles long lines with the
Knights already in a free I think that's
actually a small move order mistake I
think we should take the Queen I just
love it you're applying theory to King
um hello I think that's the best
strategy the Queen siding get cancelled
I agree with you but it's just amazing
that you're applying like chess theory
to king of the hill I just were you just
seamlessly you don't even it's a robber
I know it's nothing game you said let's
just be like shout out to Jessica lien
client with the raid what's the downside
of 93 is it or the upsides better to see
44 um just that we don't have our C pond
and move um do we use our sleep on to
get a good position or it's actually run
the kingdom no just just that it means
that
if he plays c5 we play d5 like just that
we have access to more senator squares
back okay so you'd like to go see 44
right I think so
a complete expert but I think we'll
probably transpose the theory that's why
I'm but the Danny were talking about so
okay we mean c4 they're gonna do 18-inch
five right that's partly why I like like
sometimes they have Queen age five can
we serve people work first there is that
can we start with t4 yeah we can look
into d4 I know but I don't Robert all
right let's do it Danny you know what to
do do you like to do you do you know
what to do I don't know if I do
so you could play Bishop g4 here and if
they played nice e3 we go Queen a5 and
then I play c4 after mission peace
yeah but if Bishop c4 c4 are we taking a
three I'm trying to think how this would
operate with the okay actually that's
probably good for us because their King
has a really hard time getting to the
center because especially with the pawn
on d4 and uh 906 it feels good
I feel like d5 is our is our square
we're gonna win this thing via
Scandinavian king of the hill strategy
d5 I love it I love it when you channel
your inner hammer on 54 I like before
you like it yeah I mean I'm into it I'm
into it I don't know Russian what's is
Danny don't everybody else has lovers in
the chat like I have haters in the chat
know they're rooting for you yeah they
want a adventure right now sir 96 we
have c4 I'd like to think defile
although they can do their queen set
council business there
I don't know you should you should be
too and yeah it's it's a 1996 like c4
Queen h5
but you know we're going we're going a
little bit like you know king of the
hill they're like we're kind of going
away from our play good chess strategy
going to king of the hill but what do
you think who is a little risky
unnecessarily risky man this is tough
position for us right now
really I mean I'm kind thinking it's
something like e 5 I was gonna say like
if you 5 to tip of the night we take G
to right yeah it makes pretty appetizing
maybe the palm we trade Queens and just
King rush right I think we can do that
right we like rush the king of the board
I think we can do that you like that
that would be all-in on the king of the
hill but I'm into it I'm super into it
I'm into it
ok let's calculate it if a 5 de Queen d1
they say fish bishop d1 even King ISA
because if they take up 6 and we take
like now we're not know within our King
goes in d6 and then we'll take on f3 and
3 are king like that's where our king is
actually we don't get there in time it's
really risky if we go in for that right
I kind of like it though but maybe it is
what everyone's gifting and loving of
each other buddy I love all of you thank
you for the love chat what I express my
insecurities
you
what are they thinking about like candy
seven or something maybe you Danny just
realized it's king of the hill he feels
like he should flicking seven like Danny
and somehow this game works
it's it's it's like tanking here or just
you know what do you think Danny is
talking about CrossFit people who do
CrossFit during the day can stuff
that's probably got a few more minutes
in them yeah yeah I can't see if he's
running around or something yeah he's
been doing some I mean we just have to
react here I think they're gonna do
something rash and try to run they're
getting down early and we play c4 that
are not on c3 keep you compact and yeah
I'm having the central space is very
valuable Danny might get impatient and
their Mount Rushmore king
you
okay I don't get this move is there now
they calculate the c4
yes c4 is my first instinct
you
first in last and
93 is the alternative but maybe they
didn't Bishop you for I mean seafloor
looks like the winds material the
question like what do they have fun they
all Big E 5 was my idea but it was mine
and I was like trying to talk to you off
the ledge a little bit I think it might
be a bad move like the more I look at it
the more I'm not certainly you've never
played a bad move in my book baby I mean
I certainly have to remember my game
against Roy Tasha can i lamb and I went
ok I planted but do you remember your
game against a non from my old man yeah
I do
all right that guy got lucky to look
like he practically fell into like an
odd draw unknown not holding his own
against you know man but the chess pros
they're a different animal altogether
that's it they're a horse to be specific
as a horse up their horse it's kind of a
demon horse like what is it it looks
like Bojack horseman right looks like
something that Satan would ride it in on
right
my fleece it seems supposed to ride in
on like a headless horseman yeah
hi dad Queen a5 Bishop d2 guys like that
Bishop before right
yeah do they have something there
because then maybe like de5 Bishop f3
it's like okay okay so c4 Queen a5
Bishop d2 they should be for 90 85 and
95 okay let's play c4 okay I don't
believe him hi it's just them too
offended to remain thinking about this
position
No
Queen in five of our time believing
or then queen egg for check and then
nice e6 Queens eggs before nightly
Hudler how is that in terms of king of
the hill chess 12:00 at night before
94-94 yeah I mean it's wild but we're
winning material potentially I like it
just let's do it let's do it then what
are the Castle kingside under community
for though so then they're King's way
out of the centre I guess that's the
that's the
I mean I don't know right you're asking
me questions here
I'm nervous Queeny forecastle short
knight c6 okay good night good night c3
kind of thing
right they see three
so what idea is if Queenie for castles
Bishop f3 and if Bishop a3 like Queen D
for no they were doing then we're losing
because they'll take on b7 I know but
but as king of the hill strategy
well he's not making it that's the thing
yeah d5 is under control okay so Queen B
for castles short knight c6 I feel like
that makes sense to try to clear the D
file and then Knight c3 though and then
Queen
so Queen g6 I guess but it's good so
let's not check right away let's play
jak ii let's clear it
checking let's do it let's check it out
check check check me out you're gonna be
to Bishop d2 yeah so they're gonna play
as my guess that's because they're
inexperienced and we'll play
you here overnight years inside of you
look on 1985 that's also my concern is
right what if they just start chopping
up our Center like King f1 was my first
instinct here at least a 50 - what's
wrong Bishop do just that like after
King up one I was just wondering because
even have sometimes quitting for
checking in d5 like they're very
committed to the apply you said which
move 92 Bishop DQ Bishop d2
as then if
five that's our position I think that's
a position huh there's less risk there
right right and it also I just don't
know the repercussions of King f1 and
king of the hill like about being editor
I feel like a much more real or more
secure with with playing Bishop d2 it
unless there's a different move in Queen
85 so Bishop Bishop takes then we just
take with that night we're clearly
winning something
mm-hmm yeah King f1 with our business on
you - it's not about then our King our
King we're not we're not in time - I
think if there's nothing wrong if
there's no decent variation that we're
not expecting after Bishop d2 I feel
like we there should be 2 again Queen a5
official duties United Dixie - yeah okay
yeah pay attention to the trace you were
right they played Bishop detail so we
have to take right or let me we could
like win a fight but
yeah but then I've got a Knight takes e5
so how what's our game plan here
actually I kind of like a queen a5 looks
good Kawai 595 then what
thank didn't we take only two and now I
guess we have to castle but I'm its king
of the hill right who cares of the
material
man looks not great gonna be honest
but if if Bishop d2 92 yep
Queen a 519 for five stone
we're losing a pawn no matter what I
would just like to get castlelong
because I feel like we'll have a better
chance of getting to the center running
the King yeah
Oh
so if queen a5 and they take a five
you
silence not our friend
we got to go king of the hill at some
point here man let me name five because
I think we can put them and here is time
trouble here
Oh Queen f5 just 965 right Queen 595
they're just gonna be down on that line
I don't pay are you looking at like
Queen 85 Knight takes e5 94 then after
94 hours I okay Bishop takes g4 no it
doesn't even work sorry 96 or an ID - uh
we just win a piece big both win apiece
right I'll sink my ship right no I'm
just trying to figure out what they're
planning right I was thinking that they
just taken you to Queen e2 and Castle
maybe okay never mind
so here there's no choice we take with
the night right yeah I mean could take
with the Queen but I think nice simple
good night make sure we maintain a net
on the f3 which means good for for king
of the hill I'd I guess okay
I can't help but think that 95 is good
but also Ponti's think about it but yeah
want a steak Oh 96 97 and what context
were they going Neji seven yeah
a 94 this Queenie five well well so
that's my question so if Pont extent is
having with castle how did they get out
of their mess because they're gonna then
have to deal with with moves like 95 and
94 the move after maybe didn't go in 86
so so dd5 Nate ft7 castles 96 now
Atlanta 95 and that you right so they
can't go off you
whoa so 95 yeah Bishop takes you too
9650 187 can get well remember they're
gonna go King V sevens king of the hill
probably okay but yeah yeah but I think
we can handle that oh and there's also
just queen take c2 right right after
after that but Knight takes e5 Bishop e2
Queen e2 almost feels like we're letting
them off the hill castle plays rook e8 r
FD h is kind of easy
yeah I mean at 65 is easy
oh I'll talk Eric's doing all the
talking
do you watch stranger things Danny I
haven't watched the new season no yeah I
mean they're 65 is a clean bond I don't
say anything like 1985 is the cleanest
to me just the off chance that du5 they
went up on a Harley five so
like they'll go 97 castles Bishop takes
f3 yeah Knight takes F 396 yeah yeah
something like that although I still
think that's a decent King that was it
but I know you mean it's just pawns a
pawn
I'm just wondering if it's easy for them
to play they take on you to the castle
and they like rook e8 equal tomorrow eh
well I like that we have Queen f3 right
away so 1985 Bishop e2 castles castles
mm-hmm if Ricky ate I don't know Queen
f3
yeah let's play Knight takes e5 just to
take the clean fun
take me to the Queen City I love it -
they're gonna play it was Annie she
didn't know about the Titanic ending and
he's just a titanium and he's just
enough Titanic well he did it we were
hosting the show and he was like wait
how does it end again cuz I was trying
to explain how like Jack was like can I
ruin Titanic it's too late not to ruin
Titanic Jam he's dying but making sure
that rose stayed alive and he was like
who was the old lady again I'm like Rose
is the old lady yes how does he not know
that it was horrible and he's Giri isms
somebody clipped that send it to him
boom boom look they're nervous now
they're nervous they're yeah that's for
that was okay that's right that's a nice
giri problem if he doesn't know Titanic
look they're nervous they're
appreciative they they didn't seize it
you should get a nation of heart of the
ocean for his next birthday oh it's such
a good idea
Irena Castle queenside like you wanted I
love it just do it just too fast they're
getting nervous how quickly were playing
yeah because now we're gonna we're gonna
open this thing up buttercup whoa look
at that
copy should we play Brooke over or
mmm-hmm Rick Rick
81 an idea 3G to get pieces out of the
way and convert whatever your position I
wonder what we're missing here I don't
know what a five was up there sleep I
really don't know what he thought was
five
yeah I think I
that there's I think that they don't
have anything and there's no way we
should be lower on time than them from
this point on okay
pretty simple details right yeah I'd
love to take the other way but after
like yeah F takes four tix T for Queen F
to Queen takes e5 Knight f3 plus Queen
of four checks I don't know I was trying
to find the the other line I was looking
at lucky five fifty five right now yeah
g5 could be something d5 is like the d5
Queen g4 looks like the move yep that's
annoying
and then if Queen takes e5 yeah that's a
pity that's that's a close one so let's
just take D okay look before so let's do
it
yeah let's double check because we're
not all in yet but if rook t4 clean up
to Queen b6 we're threatening rook takes
c4 with the discovery yeah but if they
play team b1 then we go Knight g4
something like that or yeah but yes
before our Kings on the diagonal no no
Ben then G for there we go being like
over you could pick h5 to protect it and
like from H to d8 kind of thing maybe
yeah I like that I like it I like it
you like it yeah I think they're all
just scared right now we're in their
head
okay no you're fine okay
you're fine I saw Queen III out of the
corner of my eye nobody five spinner
what I saw that and so I I kind of just
once I saw that I confirmed it you
started yelling wait that was let to go
but you know when you know when you
dismiss something cuz you like media
understand that we need is not a good
mood is a pin but you're like wait a
second I forgot to calculate a game but
you know I'm struggling right now with
PTSD I'm in therapy okay so also we're
doing really one the clock yeah we made
a couple we made a clock comeback yeah
don't
I mean queen f2 Brooksie for Jake now I
think we should go queen f2 when it's a
piece right I don't see anything
yeah let's try that Oh Queen b6
one Queen b6 right now okay but yes at
the end of the world
Jessica King b1
can be one knocks Allah
can't go 94 we just hit the night and
it's check on G Flula
and they can't go Knight takes e4
because we're detecting it so just came
over I like it
but yeah I guess it feels like that
probably yeah that's okay
we have ideas now if I think we know
through the respect level is so low that
I thought they hung a piece so like many
otago just played g3 although we have to
watch out for Queen g6 like just some
sort of weird counter play where like
our light squares in our King gets
punished you know I mean yep
you
so the upside of Queen f3 is queen g6
joke and that fire
sorry say that again Queen f3 we can we
can deal with Queen g6 because we can
play i-5 and at least that looks very
sharp and so we have three they're gonna
go Knight h6
where do we go energy through your queen
83 well no because I want to stop in g6
check please forgive me because I
thought will make us pick a either
really bad background a core all in the
C file if Kuna 3 night-night aged 6 we
could even play 93 there I don't know
Queen f3 though if we don't have any
move because it's native 6 we're just
gonna win the file and then we'll just
have the initiative and then they'll go
h3d rook deeds are moving night
somewhere right perhaps right but then
we have Knight takes e5 in positions ok
wait if we have Queen takes
we have Queens you six chicken they play
a 5v5 is falling but we have to be
careful right we can also play f5 here
because if they take we take back with
the night and that opens up doors for
our King to get to the center I like
your live I love that 5 no you mentioned
it do it yeah if they play you it you
know it explains me this is where on the
one in the clock there's no difference
right now sometimes we complete each
other's which is so hard we do it still
hard I don't like it when you do that I
was gonna comment you calling you my
general Maximus Meridius here and then
you went all first of all we are we are
sandwich soulmates I'll tell you that
sandwich so makes making a clock
comeback
oh yeah oh wait we could take c4 we can
we can also put our work on e4 if we
really want to that would be but so this
is a very dangerous king of the hill
spot because we're giving in 2d file at
our King is there
right you're not wrong I'll give you
that I feel like we should almost go
back to full chess here like take c4 or
threatening Knight f2 what's there mix
it takes you four throw Queen b3 then or
even Queen d5 yeah yeah that's double
although we have Queen e6 it guards
everything it'll have degree and a queen
d5 word Queen c6 you're saying yeah
well that's actually fascinating we're
so ruthless calculating it Brooksie for
Queen d3 Queen b6 they might go Knight
d4 on us
the other move is to just like come back
after 94 we have Queen d5 their owner
than at five things will check something
something should work
but brick c4 is not a move they want to
play like it's all it looks it looks
super risky yeah I'm sure it's very
awkward
but they they almost have to right
because there's no other great moves
maybe it worked DDA
yeah but when we put age to you they
don't have natives
yeah we've see five so it's that
position is my five is not a move they
want to play the passport for us and
longest diagonal so the nice thing about
our Center which is why I wanted to
always have that see pro move from the
start is that he never has a king of the
hill square like we have before if
things get all traded right yeah it's
very hard for him to stop
we're up a minute here
but you think he's gonna do probably
take on I think I think I think in time
trouble does just come threats and the
threats and throughout time you happy
missing girls but rook takes t3 you're
just running around I think you're gonna
click look at eat if they go Brooke DDD
a can we go to three night I don't even
have my III know you have no night
school soon so 96 and then yeah without
let's see
rook t5 mm-hmm looks like a great one
yeah and then if they play c6 we can
play see Bobby excuse a yeah something
nasty nice king of the hill here you
know like full king of the hill remind
me what was wrong with rook takes T for
Queen d5
no couldn't of any with Queen c6 so we
said Queen d3 queenie 694 and then we
can't go Queen d7 so rooks hanging in if
we go Queen d5 f5 sang with check
problem darn exceeding d5
wait sixty-fourth cleaned III could go
Queen d5 potentially is that
Queen b5 looks low every girl looks so
shaky looks so shaky I think we just go
back to d8 I just do it we spend a lot
of time that's do it yeah they're gonna
h3 on us and we're not gonna be happy
but we're just gonna at age six
have f23 no we don't isn't c5
oh yeah unless unless someone that opens
up the D file for us than our king can
run by on things so night h6 feels sadly
necessary sadly okay are we really sure
light a 55 garnish Morgan yeah do we go
back also we have 20 seconds we had so
much time before no but let's play the
clock a bit let's let them think that
we've lost sight of that
ooh okay so Queen Queen 6 the 195
remember we have a 10 second increment
what are we gonna do though c6
what about clean b4 to hit c4 then rook
b5 that's that's
sc6 repeat a question c6 do it with five
seconds
is it really out of the question to do
that no we needed to do it cuz work b5
was a pretty devastating threat up to
Queen before so c6 kicks them and our
knight can actually come through f7 and
back into the game and what we really
need to do is run our King b6 yeah what
are we gonna do if they go rook d3 Queen
before I like there Oh what Queen Queen
before now right
I like it I mean I just free space to
roam with and also now we have the deef
meadow 7-9 f7 I was gonna say we could
also take on d6 and we have kin d7 kid
exactly but if we get the Queen's off
the board exactly an acquaintance go to
e4 with check always and rook takes c6
check doesn't work we just taking the
King v8 we're safe
so actually this is turning and I like
it but then they get away around the
King let's do it ready you know we like
rook these six cousin shelters that
follow right yes and if I'm just
wondering a3 are we regretting it
because the Knights loose like Queen a4
or something I'm not regretting it
what's our next move
rook e1 or yes
rook do you want and mic roof t4 yep
okay
sure
not here that we at least had worked see
one as well well I was very close to
thinking that native 5 almost wins ro
takes c6 and 95 in some positions is
almost checkmate so we can set that like
so 95 okay they can maybe take on c5
what they take on c4 this is an example
take on b7 connects b7 wreck h c1 should
be lights out
but then queen c1 a 96 oh that's who
works for me okay so just Rick c1 and
where is he gonna go by the way that's
queen is 694 okay Briggs he wants it for
sure Rick c1 okay
oh yeah well we did take some time off
the clock I guess yeah
they don't really want to give up the D
file because then then our team race is
on but they want to take on d6 for the C
pawn play Knight c5 and say you're not
getting it yeah that's a great point so
we're not gonna take him right a WebWork
hte eight or whatever and or even like
cheat six if we wanted to offend f5 from
tech we also consider g5 at some moment
oh I don't know if it's good but I
noticed have a move that you enjoy
alright so Jesus g6 are tricky
just just glitchy super okay I kind of
liked rookie aid because then we yeah we
could think about that and the b3 night
still hanging I like this move though
because if they go over d1 what's the
good outlet well they're not threatening
anything right yeah different rooks c4
then we move our queen back oh but then
they're gonna put everything on the D
file so we would've used to work 88 here
prom rook 88 rook c4 and that was Queen
a6 and then the other one comes to d4
and then we trade Queens and take on
these six okay I'm trusting in Robert I
don't know if it's good their King is
gonna run like before right they're
gonna do their kingdoms gonna try to run
right to d4 that's what I'm actually
really concerned about
it was also the idea of like 94 right
now
94 and they almost have no moves like
there's no good soccer after 94
disconnects the Queen thing and we're
threatening 96 f5
example
right I'm just wondering if there's a
defense too risky for and literally
bringing well 194 crooks c4 we have like
Queen b3 okay for we don't answer that
mean the thing that I I'm yeah it's just
let's see they don't take on d6 then we
go 94 what moves it ahead
well I'm just like what do you want okay
so so so Rick see for where you were
Queens a6 and King C - I'm just curious
like how they literally have a stop King
before King c300 King C - sorry yeah you
know what you're completely right I
oughta kept thinking you're sinking into
because I think so no no that was
earlier and that was a bad fish I I'm no
no you're I just feel like we're we can
just like win I your completed or as
soon as the concept does not hit me I'm
very slow now that king of the hill
concept Guinea - I was the King C - I
mean now you're right this looks very
strong okay crap what are we doing um
seven go do it do it I don't know they
don't know king c3 we can't summon king
before we lost
the next move is kinky Fork yeah we lost
I think we just take on just do anything
gosh
no there we go you're dealing with the
king of the hill are you guys good at
King caboodle Oh Danny I mean I've just
take advantage of King during arena
Kings with a John Herschel and uh that's
my that's my experience so far yes we
love you we love you the most
I seriously I can't believe that so they
they tilted the scales and chess profs
favor then because like once in his life
I played the same amount so I was mighty
mighty five move was bad yeah we play d5
because we started having delusions that
you guys would actually just take e5 and
then the moment we played it it didn't
work out yeah that was a that was a
surprising one but I I was expecting
some type of trickery because I thought
you were already like kind of halfway
populated oh yeah well it's just that
the opening you're gonna get chased
around a lot so I knew it was something
kind of crazy but we we know Joe knows
in the chat what's that I'm telling ya
I've only played it one who's gone for
Danny John I think John is giving me and
Robert a bit of a mercy cheer because he
would like us to win but we know he's
friends with all of us and I mean I
think he's rooting for me and Robert cuz
we'd all like to see a comeback right
now okay um but I don't know uh alright
I think I think he appreciates the the
king of the hill we had a really good
time
all right I'm being told we're gonna
take a very quick break I guess yeah
yeah that's a good idea everyone so you
said a mercy cheer and I think that's
yeah we're gonna do a Mercy Mercy cheers
yeah all right I'm fairly we're taking a
quick break shout out to John who's here
everyone get there Johnny votes out and
everyone that's here don't go anywhere
we will be right back
[Music]
but it's best of best of five or three
its first of three best of out of
five it's thirty is very best of five
it's the same thing exactly I'm just
trying to explain Amman in terms of
Danny would understand yeah Danny you're
old enough to have been alive when the
NBA playoffs the first round was best to
a Suns over Lakers after being
down - well it's not I was you were good
well Steve Nash I was always a sieve
gosh you guys Mary Ann Canadian huh oh
yeah you gotta love that
absolutely hashtag Steve Nash okay I
mean I need my kid after Nash said oh
yeah and you told us for those first of
all Nash is a sexy game
alright this is I agree even maybe even
better as a first name so anyone all
right well welcome to that what are you
doing dude is he getting punished for
that loss yeah okay that actually hit me
pretty good
Danny you like cruises oh my god you
kids be nice to the producer oh my gosh
wow do you feel better now do you feel
better now
are you running awesome t-shirts are
there Sean a t-shirt gun on me no Olivia
the charity stream we promised people
that if we reached a certain amount I
would get shot with a teacher gun wait
is this getting shot yeah that was it I
just got shot with a t-shirt gun that
seems worth it already it actually isn't
that bad I mean it was kind of like a
good hard massage where you kind of the
pain is good right
like dig in there get real good in there
so thanks for doing that buddy that
could be the turnaround of the match
Robert
that's just my to relieve some stress I
might just do that whenever I was going
on here I'm so clueless oh I just got
shot with the teacher a gun live on
camera we're about to play the next game
that's all I know
all right let's do it I'm very confused
and we still don't know what it is
getting shot by a t-shirt gun hashtag
Danny things that's right Thank You KC
New York the you could donate more for
another t-shirt but you guys are already
doing so much that's this that was a
ballot that was owed to the snowballs
donations so many of you donated for
that oh my god this is ridiculous
my head hurts okay what color are we
we're white we are white you got a okay
we got to get a first move out Robert we
got to move the night to try to get a
queen how we supposed to make a choice
and we just look in the position for the
first time they're about to get a queen
on gt1 I think that makes sense nights
like 97 yeah I like that
I'm just moving I have no idea oh my
gosh this is ridiculous
Danny a very good thing is our c3 and c5
squares are covered so a knight can't go
there with me it's actually leaving more
of a mark than I thought it would a
little bit friendly that's it
equal material no we have an extra night
we have a trapeze yeah it must be to
balance it out somehow
okay so hang on a sec we can make a
queen by the way yeah these are all be
pawns correct yeah
no ki ji oh yeah yeah our King is on
each phone right correct okay okay so we
can make a queen right now and to be
honest I have to say if we make a queen
they can't make a queen didn't they just
blunder like horrendously
right they can't
now they can make it green hang on I
could take the Queen correct I know
correct I thought that they were
promoting to seem to ration that we were
so that's like if we promote no no but
that's why they started the game the way
they did they change the position right
it's not symmetrical otherwise that I am
assuming a pre move for a promotion
first would be a huge advantage I wonder
what's the no but the first move seems
valuable the nice thing about getting a
queen first as we're threatening to take
their bishop and if they take we take
with the Queen on a six so we're coming
out right and we're and we're attacking
the bishop when ahe anyway but also very
importantly we just to make sure that I
can't double-team our Bishop on a one
because they take that and take again
get Maidan right right i I think okay
I'm just gonna play I don't have auto
clean on one plane kind of quickly
because I don't want to get down on time
in a game that probably it's a coin flip
at this point what we do yeah I know
this is good for us it has to be we move
first with the white pieces yeah but
look at the material they have two more
minor they have one more minor than we
do they do wait why are we down a minor
maybe why are we down a minor he that
was actually you can't believe L is
actually still according to the engines
but whoever prepared the email is
actually still in White's favor to start
no they said minus one
oh yeah I think he meant like black his
dick like so it's closer to a white
first move advantage like a real game so
let's go with that got it I feel like we
shouldn't be allowed to quote engine
evals when we're playing the game of
chess
you know how I feel with my commentary
damn oh I know that I'm only telling you
what they're telling me that according
to this the game is close to equal so we
shouldn't be stressed even though we're
down to peace I only said that because
you said why are we down a minor it
wasn't a mistake with the Fed got it
apparently the eval is close to equal
appearance but I'm one my piece bag I
want a lie piece back
you know because I thought we were
preventing white from queening all their
pawns look as if b1 was gonna be taken
by our queen so I'm not sure queening is
the best to hurting me but
so G to Queen tha rocked xp3 King takes
p3
Queen 84
do anyone and then we're doing it all
right I mean is if little k2 then we're
Queens let me clean up yeah please like
play AG to play G
take their Bishop on h8 but that's like
a wasted issue right you want to try you
want to try to get into the Queen's we
were saying I guess I also want to try
to mate their king but I don't know how
to deal it but they're gonna go Queen f1
pawn G 1 equals Queen and the taker
Bishop on a alright
pretty straightforward plan for them and
it's super annoying
do we take on g2 and then play b7
that feels off to me but maybe
[Music]
how do we do this okay we also have this
Knight that can maybe get in the game
right I mean I don't see where it goes
this is the worst position I've ever had
it's giving me a headache I honestly
have enough so if we go Bishop - what
squares that d5 then they go Queen d1 or
something then we go beast seven they go
Queen we get Queen they take our Bishop
that's not cool
you
our bish one day one hanging is actually
a really painful situation yeah I don't
know how to fix that and I'm sure I'm
just weren't trying to calculate
anything how do we stop this plane of
the movie Miglia then we can always take
on g2 right so we can play move like
Queen to anywhere and then take next
move so we can even take their Bishop
with the intention being that we're
gonna take their pawn next move now
another thing we have to calculate is
one thing oh look takes
cb3 right because if it's a brook and if
we take with the king I don't buy it if
this eval is good for white this is look
good for black I mean like if you give
wonder if you give the computers more
time display how do we stop this plan of
rook c2 and Queen a1 like they're
sacrificing we alright we'll figure it
out okay let's keep thinking um do we
need to play Bishop d5 just done that
idea but Bishop d5 the noble Queen EU or
d1 or something
but even can you see one Queen see one
alright they're getting a queen in our
nice head if we move our beep on our v6
bomb
come on you know what this is all
revenge for right few years back Danny
in the summer him and Robert mmm a put
in mr. Carrillo yes team just brought
with me yes
took a public loss took a public loss a
very unnecessary public a public loss
and a documented loss the document the
public loss that ended up on YouTube
just yeah team we need to get as much
footage out of thing as much evidence to
the contrary that I was
you know what's weird is that
that knowing chess calm obviously they
would make the physician balance but
what seems weird to me is that we Queen
all the time on the side where their
king is and they clean all the time on
like quote unquote our Queen side like
our Queen side can fall apart and we're
not gonna get mated but when we're
cleaning on g1 and playing our palms up
like that we're activating like rook
Knight Bishop and getting to Queens I
don't think it's fully balanced that's
my impression I don't think it's fully
balanced but I know that it's not more
than would winning from aside like this
yeah but apparently the evaluation is
0.6 kind of secretly like is some idea
where we play like Queen to b8 and try
to like get the Queen on that diagonal
to like spy at the King there's a
creative room take c2 is what's worrying
worrying me right now but thank king
takes
and if check and we move the king we've
got the rook in the Queen on the
third-ranked getting the Chi three score
it was there was some meeting idea but I
like their queen g8 idea if Knight f6
Queen c4 I kind of like that alright
let's just do it I just really give me a
headache just solution will go with that
and then we'll we'll try to we'll try to
get our b-pawn rollin ASAP
I hear at least we also have the ability
to play Queen the other queen to a8
right like I guess we're getting mated
that's the problem like if if Queen f1
Queen a a they get a queen we take their
fish oh okay so let's bring our queen
back for me do you want to bring it to
e6 or two
what score is that c4 - to me I felt
like c4 was better because but east
actually East sixth eighth we can't be
attacked anymore by anything I like that
now I like mmmm yeah we can't be
attacked all right let's do that okay
I'm doing it
there's no one really really hit a can
do i I can't say that enough oh now
we're also threatening ee1 is a check on
the king they have to be very careful
right that's what I was looking at too
right well we could play queen a8 I
really don't think there's anybody that
hates suspicion more than I do
enough did you people understand hey
they get it they get it okay so yeah
Oh totally overlooked damage so what if
we go clean what
what squares that Queen d6 is that
possible unless they're pawn again
yeah but then there opens the King and
we get the other Queen in the game they
pushed the other pawn to g3 I don't
think that's bad for us for them to open
their king
okay that's do it then right and it also
pins down kind of their night oh wait
well the UH no they can't play 94 we can
take with the bishop they can't play
Knight a for or sorry 98 where do they
take on b3 now oh we did with a rook
because once they go Queen takes a one
we've cuiabá courting the check that's a
good play this is we can even take with
the King now though because there's no
Queen check out are you ready and g4 is
really good because then we activate our
queen from age 6 and our rook from h5
and our King gets shelter and the Queen
stops hitting the night on h2 it's a bit
of a race to see who can make more
useful because they don't want to have
to move their Bishop on b7 that's like
with tempo but I mean we can't move our
things so what's what's your worry there
right now from g3 g3 to me that's the
most it looks like it almost falls into
place no that's what I'm saying
I think series great move my name is G
throughs agreement
I mean in terms of efficiency you know
they're just moving her queen right now
and I feel like this is a game about
development whether that's species Arden
they're just one our knight on f6 which
is nice to know is permanently defended
by the bishop and upon so you can leave
it there
the g4 the Brooke is activated on the
rank the Queen is activated from age six
on the diagonal and we just then we move
our Queen from g1 and let's start making
Queen's basic
or f54 we can play Knight f3
okay so he goes there
so our Bishop on h8 is also defended by
the Queen and a Brook so we're in no
danger of losing that guy I'll try one
minute I'm on but I've been tendering
during the game
well these I know that these games
aren't earning a little quicker than
planned so these games not always for me
to start I'll throw some something
column I can come above it I can maybe
arrange it a little earlier
what's in them well
I mean g4 feels like a great move I feel
like we don't want to rush other moves
before that
just go chief
you
people
yes sir that's all areas all right yeah
what should we do now the reason I like
it certainly the reason I like Bishop b5
is if they take we can take with the
night we get like a threat on the rook
it all something iconic Bishop c6 was
promoted because what are they doing
like what are they have they been doing
what what progress have they made by
pushing these pawns
and our Bishop on c6 is also protected
by a pawn on whatever c5 which is a
ridiculous thing to say bitter you get
when you're irritated New York review is
like one of my favorite parts about you
also our opponent b6 is hanging if they
can move their work out yeah we're
playing b7 next baby yeah I agree with
that you never got to tell me that twice
Oh baby girl on b8 oh gosh KC New York
says get robbed some advils hey jerky
hey jerky
let's uh let's just get a queen dude
like b7 b8 like stop me prove me wrong
that's what - does he walks around the
house by the way it says like you know
he just says Kawhi Leonard's the the
goat for me wrong I like that also you
know it's cool if we do take on c6 r b5
on our b4 pawn can take the rook on a5
they turn a 5 ridiculous agree man
also they're catching up in terms of bad
clock management yeah that's good for us
that's good for us we're the team up
there work on our bishop look how gosh
c'mon Scott that like for Oh bro I'm
letting Eric run the show too much
Louisville what if they go rook e1
oh the good news is rb2 pond protects a
three I keep forgetting about so usually
dude that's sweet
that's a huge point we've been missing
[Laughter]
Simon the position is still bad for us I
feel but no but the beach people
guarding ager oh my god I literally just
like switch from coffee to something
else if you know what I'm talking about
oh my gosh
Ackerman already found some deflection
we have to watch out I'm just yeah they
might have Queen a to d8
and then Queen takes d5
you
people talking
do you want to move the Queen like Queen
to c1 or Queen to be one and then we're
threatening Brooke takes that pawn and
then Queen Jack and Queen to c2 or
something and then we make another so
Queen c1 what happens after Bishop takes
cheat you
[Music]
I'm just I just didn't see the maid and
if I don't see the mirror my
you
sure
Knight of three
Queen Queen we can flick rook takes pawn
King takes Queen checking back Queen c2
III and Bishop takes Bishop on how does
the Queen get to see - there's no peace
sorry cuz I play Queen c1 let's move is
it Oh
so rook takes an N Queens you won no
Queen see one first
that Bishop tasty - right and then I was
saying birth takes pawn yes King takes
Queen III from age six came back
Queen B sorry C to chat to cook and then
leave the bishop on just take the bishop
back because we're hitting it with our
queen okay
35 seconds you want to do that yep looks
like fun exchange and the bishop is
gonna move on the light squares like
bishops f3 to d1 or something
we could do that so we are they do have
any kind of work takes me three threats
not really right or we just take back
with our King
are they teaming up to meet us up there
I don't think so if we take G to baby
there maybe they're playing rookie one
so they can take a one but our Park King
on 83 is still protected by pawn but
that is kind of noise
one idea we have if they move the rook
off of g3s ladies free with our queen
and try to draw the King out for example
where's their Bishop g2 rook e1 bishop
h1 if they take a1 we have Queen g3
contains that I mean Queen comes to g2
or we throw the other Queen and
immediately the same idea I like it
Bishop takes pawn let's do it let's do
it
so oh nice move I don't know if it works
for them but I'm proud of it that's what
I was succeeding that they were gonna do
that but it wasn't what does it do
but if we take care of the Queen each
city with the rook though Queen a wanted
them look back to a3 and our Queens
guarding d1 and they go Queen takes b2
and then what do we do Queen tu but no
but our rook is our rook is hitting g3
we're threading Queen takes g3 oh you're
right
you're so right do it just take with the
root of the Rope take of the room take
with the run I feel like they're on tilt
I feel like this is your poem you just
made me so happy Danny this is just uh
take on
okay so Queen takes check rook blocks
Queen takes b2
that looks good because then if
bishop
yeah just just do that oh hang on this
his Queen takes pawn on g3 that's coming
for him
thank the new trouble
first take care check
and then what queen back to e1 you want
how many moves do we have here no I
think we should sack and then he takes
the king we give it a check if it takes
yeah yeah that's very clear because I
just
okay now we have to calculate so
you
this is awesome this is so cool
oh and but they have Quincy for what
we know we're square C 4 I mean me and
they had they had Queen C 1 and if we
move they could have played Queen C 4
but they didn't do it
oh so King do you know that's where we
gotta go yeah yeah I'm what I was saying
is if they played Queen c1 King hu Queen
c4 b3 Queen c2 they have a draw we
didn't see that no boy that's a queen c1
we'd nothing we were king
right I guess we could have put our own
queen on like d3 or something yeah okay
but can you just look at take what the
Queen I think just hate it yeah of
course that only helps us cuz that we
even take on each two if we want okay so
do we go our queens under attack so you
can also play quitting dhf watch out
nice III check our pond covers that
square just from the earth so we could
take the pawn on whatever square that is
I can't even realize what square that is
g6 well we don't you can also give a
check on what square is that d8 is that
what you said oh we also Queen c7 check
to pick up the night perhaps
ooh I like Queenie 7 check actually
Queenie 7 they push the pawn we take not
that we just take tonight that was good
to me I like it a lot
oh but also wait why why didn't they
play that sooner
that's very good right yeah
take that pawn obviously right
musics yeah I don't know otherwise we're
just down Queens right or now yep
and we can take the night which guards
the pond I'm assuming there might be a
tactic for them though by the way like
for example Queen to e1 here this is
twice better friends oh good you're here
yeah that's over the net so because
I think that's a good move I don't see
anything really to be honest I don't see
anything
I don't have I don't have a move
okay that was good so now our volumes
back on I'm positive he's gonna be Danny
it was completely winning I'm positive
we thought you guys were totally winning
out of the opening yeah we we were but
then we thought we'd like tread check
meet you
yes so yeah like we were Devon we were
definitely instead of Knight f6 like
what if you guys just like move McQueen
and go for that same plan right away
like poison d1 yeah quit d1 like or even
just looking at Queen c1 or Queen e1
like trying to get a second Queen as
quickly as possible yeah I mean I guess
what you did was also good right Knight
f6 rook up yeah we just thought we were
getting all his free moves yeah I think
puppy probably g3 was your first
official mistake just BAE oh you're
amazing
like g3 is just not good sorry good well
can we just do that without sacrificing
we sacrificed but can we just not
yeah we're just like cuz we could just
play chess but then we got excited with
TQ Orson please Queen c1 is like we miss
tortoise you know what we forgot guy we
forgot that the b2 plum was guarding a
tree so you know panicking
we were panicking about you guys just
playing like rook e1 rook takes a one
row takes a three and mating us right we
forgot the beet soup on capital e forgot
we realized that about halfway through
and we like breathes a sigh of relief we
thought you were winning the whole time
Jo yeah we thought we were winning so
much so that we played the rook takes
pawn that was probably also our demise
was Cyrus crying thank you for 10,000
more bits from fiery scribe this is the
most amazing experience of Roberts life
I'll say that but alright apparently I'm
being told by our producers because this
could turn into an epic match we need to
keep going so next game is coming up no
breaks no rest for the weary okay
Eric you got your solo cup you do but
I'm gonna have you put the Eric in
America just say oh okay check the game
that's first thing what are we playing
we're playing nine six ninety sixty got
it fifteen minutes too much time again
Danny what's going on here yeah we may
have to play faster sighs which is okay
I'm evaluating it 960 I just did a video
on chess960 fYI wait why do we have a
five-minute time event
oh they did adjust at the clocks because
of what you said they listened to me I
loved it they were like yeah this shows
running a little long let's speed this
thing up okay so what is going on here
so our night sir guys in the corner
don't like that we can always Castle
kingside
or we use Castle queenside I feel like
you know it's so much stuff I keep
thinking about moving by night so I can
get a queen
oh my god Tommy coming through it with
the bits and the amount that only he
knows how to do yep some people are into
it be alright so they go for the center
it's dude I'm literally thinking
backwards right now I have no meat
instinctively I want to play either f6
to open up the bishop or just copy them
with e5e5e5 do it yeah I think that I
think we should just play chess here
right
you know what I think we should be
preparing to Castle short yeah we got
some long in class parties - yeah okay
castles short in real chess right yeah
so it's long in this game okay so like
we want like 96 f6 like try to go for d5
to fight for the center and then I don't
know that would be my although as I say
that they may change the plan for us
right if it's possible that we might not
even needs a castle depending on what
happens oh okay that is so they want d4
can you drop it on top of the brook so I
just need to move the light squared
bishop for correct no you need to move
light square bishop any to move the rook
otherwise you can't guess cuz the
Brooklyn II was the queenside castling
right yeah okay if you put the King on
top of the rook on d1 then it will want
to throw you all the way to D 1 and F 1
so those pieces up all of them yeah okay
that g3 well g3 what happens after d4 I
feel like the ideal thing is like d4 93
f4 I don't have answers I just will make
movement inside I feel like we over
thought the last game with somehow I
were slow doing too much
Billie weren't slow we just like got
addicted to trying to win her a good
position immediately
take the center yeah he directs because
I think the knight doesn't want to go to
f3 we need to plat for a for maybe if
you play out for a night of three night
goes to g3 for sure I mean like f4 night
of three or f4 93 there should be three
and I g3
sorry you wanna put g3 right now or
night III you don't care about Bishop f4
check
but doesn't make d3 specifically stop
that oh you said 93 soccer matches yes
Nate and I want to play off four
actually yeah no I heard mention 93 yeah
that's good
we'll run them over is that the plan
yeah I I move I would consider if I was
them would might be f5 here yeah I
thought about zero when the light screws
we do retain the option that moves like
f3 there we also retain the option of
taking you plane a t-38 or no offense
would be so awkward right let's to f5
we're we're doing one the clock when we
feel calm and even if we're not doing
well that's too bad we're having a great
time we're having a ball don't stop me
now Danny
don't start believe no that's not the
song okay so don't stop me now I don't
oh I don't know that song as well as
journey I'm having such a good time I'm
having a ball
is that like a Hugh Jackman song what
are you serious right now
it's Oh duh sorry I just hurt me no but
my my kids have been playing that that's
that the greatest showmen I've been
hearing all kinds of music from the
greatest showmen okay that movie and
there's like a song that's like a like a
do do do do do do do do do that there's
a similar yeah but you don't make that
mistake first why did you Jack what is
the last true triple threat okay
what his sing is not very good okay you
wash your mouth out you guys enough what
you're talking I'm just saying shut your
mouth when you're talking to me huge
Ackman for the win
oh come on this is all on you buddy I
think I can go further this is
this is a tough one like at f3
the lazy move but we're trying to
pretend we're keeping all the squares
right mm-hmm
well I mean I'm really dry by now 93 or
something
it looks slow at the same time black is
from to force us to commit early and
they won't if they were playing at f/16
if I would be you know defiled anything
we play if I right now
yeah you're a for Bishop d5 like this
seems in the rain exactly six to
undermine rain will put half through
without ending
to keep the Integra 504 didn't look good
after yeah I didn't see how to anger -
and then they had always squares
cheers buddy oh I wish I was drinking
with my being your red cup there I'm uh
I was just showing some still water with
you that's good a bottle of water or
filtered water I'm trying to get you on
the why I haven't had a ball Oh
excellent excellent
they're coming after us are we concerned
I'm not sure we are 93
but we're gonna do it boys will do it
now when they can't back up at 5:00 with
g6 right yeah oh I really appreciate
that man Wow yeah do it buddy
maybe he plays nine at forest no can we
take on that five then and play night
back to you three
maybe he takes and does it
thanks for it doesn't butter now take
you for yeah so I was looking at taking
on e4 and does it mean I threw something
like that looks
okay at least we
we witness and we will ascend
what if we what if we just played Bishop
before check which there's no way they
saw and then 96 now we're not blocking
our dish right issue before King c2 96
and we're threatening to take G 3 and
take you for just one yeah let's do it
right let's do it there's no way they
saw this I think that's a blunder
because 96 there's no way you're happy
with the King on c2 right yeah King C
296 if okay if I 5 we can play 95 the
world right we're gonna Castle kingside
and get out they can't cancel anymore
they cannot cast them one that's big for
us another thing I'm thinking about is
what if we take on Eve now we don't
really wanting I think we should go 96
trust the line ok 96 though I like it I
like it
cuz I queued at any moment we could like
if they played b3 we can like we can
cash in we can take d3 take g3 and my
take e4 like it's not a good structure
for that if we Castle short by the way
in positions where the F files open look
at that rook grab in the f5 real quick
oh yeah oh he conned us we should keep
an idea like we might take you four and
Castle short look at their king on c2
Grizz laugh at that a little more thanks
for asking big remember remember a big
al yeah but why this season with the
username drugs are bad okay okay what's
funny is I use these things around my
kids at the house and my wife looks at
me like that's not okay
like I just say like like and they don't
know they don't get the reference and I
love it I there's nothing I love more
than holding a pop-culture reference
over my kid's head well I'm holding the
last one over your head
and that it just hurt me that you got it
wrong but also what's your favorite song
from gritty shows really no excuse
because I actually just saw Bohemian
Rhapsody great movie by the way I just
saw it yeah and and so I do that don't
stop me now let's go anyway but I will
tell you I had the greatest showmen my
wife is really big into soundtracks we
listened to Hamilton enough times for me
to like you know strangle myself I would
never say you know a small child but you
get it over this clean one okay so I
mean I'm fine with me five but B three
was really nice is it this clean three
movers bothering Queen eighty-three
looks strong
95 8 more 97 to have really good squares
there and we have t6 common so yes we
can play 90 to the Turkish bench 6 no
they don't even have to you don't even
have to know about that that looks like
way too many holes
just like Queen one then one I agree
let's try to stay flexible
you
Thank You Tommy for the support great to
see
tack yeah that's a good point okay so so
what is your idea - here we go Effie for
my India was Effie for and looked for a
chance to take oh my god may pray Oh
what the you don't know he went 200 big
ones on this whoa I love that guy
I know hey I know that guy via symbol oh
thanks man thank you
so what we go again
you're I'm thinking also a Fe for like
rookie eight ideas Bishop try3 at some
moment I don't want to take on g3 though
if a thief or 94-94 queenie for rookies
is just trapping the queen in a little
board you know they have 95 but also
weeks people yes 95 friends before
they'll take with the fr right okay and
then we're how we're gonna follow it up
we want to get the queen up and then
castle short right like some weird
positions where or maybe by crook e8 and
Castle long you know castles short long
whatever you want to call that's a good
idea
I'll only eight now
i I think we just have to take with the
pond or something Knight takes looks
wrong right yeah sorry
you
thanks the map real
Castle queenside
or Queen f5 they're both possible oh
right true cuz the partition so
something tells me we should we should
make that position a weakness and take
g3 unless Verve okay here's a crazy
question is that kilo c2 in more danger
than we realize like a rookie 85 and we
just like Castle queenside right you
know in some positions are we like
threatening to like blow it open right
like take e5 and just I think they'll
put Queen before and try to treat me
that way because once we not a good shot
to watch out for so I think Bishop g3
makes a lot of sense and if they take
with the pawn we just play rook e8
that's already yet yeah let's do it
let's keep playing fast too because you
know at this point like we want to keep
the pressure on and so it's rook e8
necessary it's one of my questions
Aquaman
we love you man
oh why not it's for a good cause he says
rookie a let's do Ricky eight I think I
like it yeah so ii 5 is for sure gonna
be played
no this isn't it this isn't it I mean
let's play you 5 I lost you uh I don't
see a like you can't leave the pawn
there cuz he can sack and play d5 or
something so God be5 right that's right
kitty-kitty
it's just like dog belonging Queen where
a five no what I said is he gonna play
Osiris understood no but King we're
playing b3 in King V 2 exactly and
that's what we want the night nice not
very good 25
yeah play b3 next I guess III can be to
unscrew the black guy I'm fast
why did they give up the bishop like
that because our GG pawns do you think
it's a reasonable though because I think
that after like 95 b3 Bishop takes rook
t3 long night 95 I'm playing 95
Oh thought we said be 395 moving on if I
were moving yes
okay tickety
and III mean okay but then we can play
workout three up and at least they're
not getting like that that really like I
don't Karl sometimes you like buying we
we play workout three work f-18 for
they're gonna get one night on a good
square I think it's a good square is
that gonna be
you said no I'm worried about a long
pass on key sticks like okay
yeah somewhere
so if 95 he's 26 by the way
all right I see five Queen f5 is at
least in the air yeah so Queen at five
or Kingston one do we want to play
because literally like after King c1 of
Quincy poverty we are doing betting 8th
for p3 Mercado we have Bishop e3 instead
of repeating yeah
what about like your knight c5 they play
d6 so we can't play that right yeah I
mean 95 d 694
so be 3d 33333 yeah but this night 83
there we have a bad position so how
about we play for first or those moves
like Queenie for here that I'm curious
about
I'm not sure that are like
I think a four makes sense first and
then 97 and then either be three or
briefing like king see three years
something every day no kings ever did
what I agree start with you Danny gonna
tell you I'm proud of you didn't just
come back to us when I say it say it
again
did I think they heard it because of you
oh that was supposed to be private I
know you let your lover he's jailed by
accident they heard you that was a
personal conversation yeah oh but
seriously dude we're all plain dimas'
black here okay up to 1960 game we well
they just totally for God to be this
fishery before check forcing your kid
that was that was but the thing is we
spotted that idea early we were already
eyeing it I told you c6 was a nice move
nice it was a nice move by you man that
was it just gave us flexibility that's a
really important thing in Fischer random
is yeah not be to yourself to either
side the board especially when you're
king and Castle the other wing as you
point out in the beginning you're like
oh you we can cast them together of rook
to FA can do g8 and it's important to
keep in mind yeah awesome we're now we
give ourselves a lot of flexibility
because we've got this d6 idea with like
castles long and just blow open the
files and then kitty-kitty hiss hiss
just went nuts whoa honey gifted subs to
the community after I say kitty kitty I
want to go yes yes is that like is that
this want us to do that that's fully
targeting whoa what dude this is what we
wanted ranked is now a three week yeah
but so which move do we want to play -
I'm a bishop defo I'd like to be 25 your
idea cuz it just hits cheat - also they
have they have no move because it's full
of money yeah yeah let's - Bishop defy
let's just trust our instincts and do it
just back up also we're moving so
quickly and it makes me feel so good
because you've always said Robert you'd
be a better bliss player but just move
quickly and now we're doing it we're
putting you've gone to 2900 blitz bro
but I dropped my rating back 20 no but
you've gotten so much better at blitz I
mean I you know I know the talent was
there do but you've been you've been
crushed up listen you guys don't follow
Robert S on chess calm you don't know
that he's been ballin
balmy maybe hey just don't balmy surely
[Laughter]
your plane but we get some Leslie Beale
said love Leslie what's his name Oh
along those girls everywhere and all
them is that true Brendan goes off that
looks very forced I think everyone can
agree to that's a real force
conversation no no no
like like they're not going to go d6
before casting right isn't it
there's your council first like
but now it's like an annoying but what
are they for now I thought you wanted
yeah
it sure 97
metaphor wait no no ninety-seven
metaphor we can't
you can take any five yeah what if we
could take on d5 about the night
recapturing you sure we get our two
bishops but the question is not to
mention something even like King b2 even
H and we got the bishop I think that
yeah the thing is he's castling just
don't forget how does he counseled you
just like it appears in d8 right this is
very hard for me to visualize all you
visualize it's the king and rook on the
sea so so so what do we do against that
I'm not ready to lose yet come on
Queen a5 or something yeah probably king
b2
it's hard to stay in this position you
know like without activating your thumb
d1 we need to get them in time trouble
too hard so take with the pawn my you
soon
yes and then we get counterplay because
they made between 85 and Bishop takes p6
a 95 right for example take take
queenside castle 25 b6 which would be 6
right - you don't have a knight anymore
in the ring not clicking back with the
pond yeah I mean he's gonna do Nate
tasty 5
where it's so frustrating I know that's
why I always drag the king all the way
over just to make sure now we should
just take you five right open up
or should we go 96 first yeah I think we
so defy you also hit the b3 pawn like
you were talking about like Queen but
there's nothing concrete there yeah and
they can take on d6 by 95 Bishop c2 or
they worship C so what if we yeah I like
your knight e6 move it feels patient and
disciplined but maybe it's too patient
and I mean the problem little bit I mean
like the other good thing about ninety
six is that then when we take on e5 and
they take back with the pawn is like is
our night immediately I want to get
immediate threats on the D file but
actually I don't see a way to do that
but we can just wait b8 if we take e5
and just plate no maybe that's not good
cuz they'll get a battery on the
diagonal
I feel like instincts say we sheets
build detention like are they ever gonna
take on d6 like that's not a good idea
let's leave that Bishop out of the game
and not take on e5 all right yeah that's
what Robert has would teach me he would
say so thanks I like 96 doing detention
why open up the bishop on g1 why take on
e5 and give them freedom right they're
gonna play Bishop C - yep they did it so
the questions do it's like king b8 first
yeah like prophylaxis I'm just gonna do
it real quick we're still up on time I
like it or our position looks good too
also we have an 8 an f5 it's a moment if
we they are unwinding though you got to
give him credit right Oh they've done a
great job of trying to get out of this
key King
they should go G for Bishop Miege - at
some point but that doesn't really help
can you just hi Nate yeah they don't
have f1 is a square I mean what if we
take I worry about rook F 1 what if we
take any five how are they taking back
look the pod then we go c5 I feel like I
like c5 a lot so take it in victim for
the night then they'll have nicely yeah
that's good take on e5 yeah so now we
take and now they also know how all man
c5 good for us this is so good for us
and they don't have they don't have
workup one anymore
they also don't have like we need just
be six now and we also thank you for 94
well it seems to leave them open for
possibility does he have some ideas
gameplay 94 94 does work up to 27 I
don't know if we can take on c5 there I
think we can because we can take back on
c2 with our other but if not if not
you
should be moving the room
we was
ricky-rock t1c 1485
agree
that definitely that if he goes b6 we
take him d5 I'm saying c4 was well as
concerned about yep
yeah you know I mean a clean 85 is rich
we want 25 when they expose their
backside c4 if they don't do that work
t1 I mean we're preparing to maybe W
want to move the rope from each of these
okay
yeah I wasn't sure if we wanted to work
on anyone for like he plays b6 then we
don't really have any five as much but 6
we go night up to 94
they're Kings know that that's their
problem is they don't want to play
position in energy all right we're just
skipping up a pawn and getting a big
initiative if we get our d6
that'll be more they go b6 we are
getting there we could if you wanted to
you want a double here I'm gonna be I'm
gonna say yes I'm on I'm gonna agree
and if Bishop before
times 95 works but we have to think
about we need to assault these guys and
their King side over here I mean a queen
size
what happens after a bishop before maybe
I have more perfect
no complaints for me anymore
I think we are making a comeback
both blame the board and on the time and
as this position gets loose and we get
one time the bishops are gonna say hello
there their cover their blogs people
underestimate them
Danny's gonna underestimate them but the
other day he's gonna kiss kiss the
bishop there it's dangerous it's
dangerous here
there's even an f4 on the spot right
stand up erection throw pieces around
there's no night at 4:00 now c5 is kind
of hanging but not really 95 95 b6 bit
of d6 Ford is clean before the work
moves
is a five ever an idea
maybe not then the he always has c4 I'm
gonna place a first there should be
three precise 9nf for 9f
yeah hey what's happening after c-45 and
d6 Bishop Dix please take special kin oh
whoa
that's a night at 4:00 right just not up
for it don't have no question about it
no question about it okay pawn takes
chief for now five sir
f5 and e6 and Bishop at me what's a g6
on g4 yeah yeah and if see forever just
like over Oh
some confidences we were suffering this
game him on this is this we got a he's
got a plane 84
what else do we do just move I don't
know we I'm a mover two seconds
yeah how do we we blew this
the good news is were threatening 94 now
that's the one piece of good news
94 what um
takes you to know don't definite ache
that Queen
he's so keenly kamiki need I don't know
get out of the diagonal do you make them
move a zero seconds left
no 10 seconds okay I see till 10 seconds
on the Oh may I know refresh
we're not out of this no one I mean we
can play qi6 can't we take can we play
g6 on them on their phones whoa whoa we
over love that then take and then play G
6 maybe do it yeah yeah
I'm so upset wide open
don't give up on me baby I'm not giving
up on you but I'm really upset though I
know we definitely messed it up okay we
they defended resourcefully we mess it
up there we just played badly okay but
this is like they have to watch out for
things on C - okay can we take a five
what is their threat we da man
we have trouble they're gonna ticker the
bishop okay so now we have Queen to e6
we have queenie 6 and with reading 25
chef yeah
interrupts then queenie to is like a
counter shot
okay looks a little better than did
before but just a little bit also feel
like Bishop c6 in some positions right
Queen c2
no there's not we can take on c8 there
and play rook to you or queen
sorry what do you want to do what we can
five takes no we can just take out CA we
can just take on oh oh you mean
immediately yeah right so he might throw
in like a Queenie five
I don't believe it
but but if 25 we we can even play yeah
you do whatever you want so takes
Tigs Queen Queen f2 King where
d - I mean c1
there's no perpetual there well we can
be c5 king b1 yeah no and then Queen f5
okay I don't know why I didn't do that
okay look t2 or Queen h8 or what you
want to do just go Queen just go Queen
e3 yep and we have up d2 Queen d4 just
soon sure dark squares mm-hmm but it's
not even the end of the world now it
looks pretty bad for us yeah okay so
then how do we deal with that right now
like make anymore if h5 now Queen f3
takes takes h4 we get h3 does that help
know how queen g6 just again some time
even though we're not we're not happy
about it
it's a queen g6 yeah they have clean t5
check Tony issues yeah so now we play
Bishop e6 we're gonna show you a five
yeah one of those h5 and the Bishop c4 I
mean we need to push the h1 yeah no
maybe this should be six you like which
one I'm not sure I like H quiet let's do
it guys keeping the bishop close to the
king
yeah got king-8 six right mm huh
they're gonna be for it but I think we
have to we have no choice right
everything else if we know we could
trade Queens and then play Bishop c4 can
we hold that no we can't no I thought
maybe we could sadly
by the way seen four doesn't really
threatened b5 Queen f6 check we would
have okay this move now we have Queen f6
check or Bishop
we got to find one something fast okay
Bishop c4 and if they check we go back
but they're gonna rip c7 that's the big
problem so we have to attack the clean
yeah b6 but it looks looks too littles
bad looks bad
looks bad man I'm so upset right now
I hardly read mrs. Keane I don't
remember where we were robbed we'll
figure that afterwards let's okay move
it until they beat us
yeah what's the winner
you want to just play a five here yeah
I agree
you
think about
well that's a good sign this is is it
made close to me
that's me
is it Chuck can be a I was gonna say
that if we put Queen Suites here
yeah moving the bishop yeah like we're
supposed to win material Queen a5 King
be to Queenie five
25:26 year
sure
I can always bail with Queen c3 after
the Queen e5 check
yes sir King
II - I guess you too
five King be one Queen e1 King a rook c1
Bishop f5 on the movie one Sharon
we got to it see no their moose where
their king goin rooks e 1me Bishop f5 -
check
but the very least they admit is a
little bit more than they probably
should still be winning here but also
their time management has not been ideal
so if I only move right we got to get
the image of getting our bishop belt
from being attacked okay so now Queen D
wait where's your kingdom for Queen e2 -
we have a perpetual suet oh my gosh so
King a3 Queen a5 Queen 84 we can work
Queen somewhere so Queen a5 check
you have to Queen a 4-week Queenie five
right only moves Ellie is Queenie eight
though he doesn't have plenty eight yeah
Queenie five and we can't trade Queens
and then play like H for maybe 10 so
it's risky but no we don't want to do
that probably we got to keep the Queens
on the board they should still be
winning but they've definitely made this
a wide-open affair that's it
they're threatening okay but but now we
can play Bishop c8 did you see
definitely definitely see yep if they
play Queen FA we have Queen 85
that so what if we go you'll get a 6 ok
also Queen d6 check was an annoying
threat what if we play Queen d5 here
network e8
like I don't know what's their next move
I guess we quit my teacher should we try
to keep the Queen on the a1 square with
like you guys quit yeah okay let's try
that also were threatening go Bishop
takes a six
right so if they play like Queenie seven
will trade coins and take a sex yeah
Wow we don't lose this game miracle
miracle
and those are able to play b5 if their
Queenie wasn't gonna take it with check
and then Queen takes a six or eight we
should keep that in mind yeah all I
think of rookie a we made them unable Oh
Darrell's here what's up Dean bunny
where's Darryl I want you to take me up
on that offer buddy you know it's not
about me today oh there is gifting somes
Darryl Darryl it did you take me up on
that offer could change the world
whoa can we just take oh there's a queen
up for check that's there it is a queen
up for check I don't even know if we
gonna do queen up or take we should like
basic statistic Bishop's here Ricky five
yeah
King c7 F 5 kt 6f6 hitting h5 okay yeah
just play it that was our plan so yeah
h4 f v h3 f6 h - just work age 5
[Music]
but I think this is working yep three is
it's fine and king c7 is too slow and
now know the half the place three yeah
so f6
grab it right and then here before we
can just give just play up seven up
seven as well
yeah probably everything wins but that's
the penis for sure
you
here we go had to come back from that
I hope they can hear me say that here is
a what wouldn't that was a bad start to
that game we've really let that position
off the hook well we we understood how
we lost our last game so we figured we'd
give you a chance in the position twenty
seconds to three minutes and we're like
you know what let's that Danny implode
let's just stay in the game first of all
we didn't implode at all I don't know
how you guys got out of that but but
like you didn't seize them initiative
what should we have done differently we
still don't know well I I was concerned
about things
opening up earlier I can't I can't even
see the moves to this game actually I
came in Danny you're 94 move was
probably better then gone work see eight
uh 94 we were gonna go what rookie -
thank you for the gift there
thank you I forget who that was I missed
your name w I was too focused on it yes
94 with like I don't know eight or what
Danny I think we take them take you guys
in basketball the guy goes the group
classes three times a week and all of a
sudden he's a basketball player this is
a serious issue oh it's got a serious
issue it's a very serious issue
there's no idea you guys have no idea
it's American
it's an American I don't even know how
any of the basket hearing in
remember how you guys thought that you
know but I'm American chess players now
right I'll be great okay we're breaking
we're gonna finish this fight in a
minute when we come right back this is
yeah great
[Music]
I don't know whether it was daryl morey
showing up in the chat for those of you
don't know Houston Rockets GM or just
that Eric's elixir finally getting the
best of him but basketball is now on the
table and it's going to happen talking
to these two guys off the air apparently
a bond like had to defend himself on the
streets apparently he's moving Harrelson
or something I don't know what Road any
scar bruise from Scarborough that's
that's a good front so we're gonna do
this this basketball things have we just
got to figure out a place in a date
where we're all in the same place I mean
but we're ready let's go let's go games
on games on alright okay but what our
next games gonna be we played chess 960
we are winging this is chess I can't
tell yet but I'm making a move I think
it's just
okay it's normal chess we're going in a
normal chess how did we let them escape
that game
I don't know we should have played d4
again or like taking me five quick let's
play quickly maybe taking e5 was still
bad opening up that Bishop but we
definitely let them off the hook so I'm
so upset about that we're crushing them
- we were up on the clock and up on the
position we totally blew it a hundred
percent let's go D for us keep doing
what we've been doing yeah let's let's
play this English attack and see if they
want to go for this again
Premal yeah I like it when you know I
don't think that was good for them as
they think it was I mean it wasn't
that's for sure so I'm willing to repeat
that Tara goes are you letting Danny
Danny and I were a collective cohesive
and we're uh we're a a give-and-take
relationship so I like you I like you
five but what do you want to do
something else no I mean it's it's up to
them - to refute it right yeah I I like
it it's not totally ridiculous though
it's like sure sure it doesn't look that
bad
because it doesn't look that bad and
it's not totally normal I'm a big fan
is that the same move yeah I get it or
at the exact same position
okay so they like their position was
there any point where you felt they
could have done a better mood no I've
never thought we were in trouble cuz
I'll tell you one moment I'll tell you
one moment where I thought they
should've played a better move um it's
much later on but it's when they played
it's when they should have or could have
played rook to c1 attacking our queen
yes
let me put queen b 7 and appendix
lubricating ray right don't think that
position was bad
that's okay yeah but otherwise I think
our position was so nice we did d6 or
give it a d6 here thing can we do
briefly attack it should be not true
because they can't play out for it looks
like an improvement to me unless I
suggest the d6 last hi yeah I was
worried about Queen g3 whatever reason
but then after King g3 there's a
for in g7 rook age 7
and some night move although Queen well
that's that's at least a draw could you
survive yeah that's so that's why I've
had this okay we can plan
you
okay she wasn't intentional right there
they they were worried about this Bishop
e6 stuff so what if we just do your
Bishop d3 first that way
instinctively I like that I feel like
it's safe let's do it
I don't even need to think too long
about it we can always play h3 later
also I would wait sometimes you play
these positions with light you still
play h3 again just because it it's
friends at 4 but a lot of times you can
play h3 and just work H to e1 and like
then you're playing f4 e 5f5 it's that
good you know that's how you take
advantage of h5 you sort of switch gears
we might not even need Age 3 in some of
these lines yeah now
the thing I like about each three okay
that would be a transposition but okay
we don't have to we can play brook he1
and very no age three it looks good I
like it I think so too because like
again they still like that previous game
I think if we don't blunder this whole
g4 idea that we were fine
wait so do we should we consider 984 we
don't have to do it but 94 now actually
my throat's been 92 no yeah this is the
right approach they're gonna play a 5 ok
and what he wants to just play f4 and if
they take d3 we take and the point is
like if they play a 4 and I see one
b3 we lock it up with a 3 we can also
play yeah for looks good
it's a Vincent different afro they might
go night see for after f4 does that
possibly know then we can we can even
take it or play or know if night FF for
nicéphore we can play Bishop c1 yeah for
almost the other move though is 90 to d4
here because we might need to trade
disappearances
oh I can say here do you need to go well
I mean I get another drink in it you
could get a magic okay this is like yeah
nice
you
dude can I sign up for the Sicilian
every time I have a good score this is
sad like this is something to be my
screen see art wall
the one thing with your thought one
thing is another purchase I employ you
you adopted some specifics so you don't
get a lot of these position great if you
yeah that's that's the downside of
planes
but this is a this is a normal tire yeah
but I I'm enjoying not be Castle it just
feels like it flows
win or lose this is how I'd like to play
this awesome I played Danny a long time
so no we ended up drawing in a quickie
but it was earlier in the game it was by
the use buddy
he how was the FM he was either a strong
FM or baby I am I think this baby I am
so lucky
like Sarah like really close to 2,400
but we had a real good when was this mm
incorporated and I was playing at that
time the classical facility so d6 like
the night or from dragon but in 96 sorry
yeah me d69 of 6m in 96 instead of AZ
and that leads to a lot of similar
position here
and if tasting c4 takes takes us to live
what's wrong with 90 - thank you -
they're gonna take on e3 yeah we take
back
and then D 5 and then e 5 like because
II thought and then just night even
Queen g 3 there a 94 like they're not
attacking this that's what I like about
nice transition this transition fun
all right also I don't know if I've seen
a minor piece configuration
you mean it's kind of fun and cute
original yeah look they're all listen to
compact structure yeah yeah
[Music]
dudu
do they do
sure like bitten they were not expecting
that yeah they did I wonder if they're
looking at 93 what
we're just taking a prone item b3 oh
there yeah
daryl morey coming through big time with
the donation
row that's my boy Darryl
all right so what do they they're gonna
take an eager to take on D to take a
deep I'm gonna pre move taking back on
III in case they do it yeah well we
always pre-boot capture kids okay how's
this ninety three twenty three eighty
four G
all respect I'll let me take over
how worried are you because we have the
possibility
sorry if what pawn to d5 55 then maybe
we take a bit so we argue that we closed
the position down maybe that
right I was thinking could even play d5
right away that's why I'm ng5 you five I
mean D fabric away without it I'm taking
oh okay
I meant like instead of 84 but he could
also pay for d4 d5 but in general it's
like okay the position has to be good
for us
right take that bishop like we didn't
play 94 not to take that bishop we're
not taking a d2 and we're we're not you
try to fix my microphone unless for some
reason you're attracted to them with d5
right now but I wouldn't suggest
anything set 93 what do you think about
93 Queen Dixie 3 H 4
not so bad
just that it means we don't have to
I'm trying to think about this because
we can obviously put tonight's c4 for
Pawnee five kind of thing I'm not sure
five square though you don't give the
what the d5 so yeah that's true and if
Knight c4 they can play d5 anyway but
then mmm but then then we can maybe 395
we also want to I feel like now that the
H miles down we should just
instinctively play broke f1 a rookie one
here get the other rook in the center
like quickly and then we can go for like
f5 and try to try to open up a file you
look up on f5 what wouldn't eat 1 and E
5 another thing I'm thinking about
Danny's of Knights 85-95 big no queenie
5 and target their queen sized ball
because the a5 pawn is really weak in
these ending okay so what's your line so
I get night C 4 D 5 D 5 e takes Knight
takes Queen e5 and if they trade we take
with the pawn exactly then a5 is a
target we would make d t6 and some lines
I feel like we get that's interesting
that's a nice positional transition but
it's 94 what if Bishop a6 is there 966
check there Oh
but if Queen takes we have IVA live or
live yeah live I think
or Bishop e5 check or something like
that looks I like it let's do it feels
good Hollywood feels good Hollywood all
right we're getting aggressive here if
it's lovin lovin your mousse is wrong I
don't want to be right I never wanted
you to be right once the lesson oh we're
right by milk say you know still looking
g5 but if I was not normally the move
point 95 in your happy
I think he might take on a d6 like like
like like
ephod
and if you take with a pawn like he
fives a liability if you take with a
piece
what's the attack now all the way I'm
looking at context e6 in 96
no I mean socially five details either
mm-hmm context 95 yeah and by Queen f3
yeah
no Kuna 3 Bishop Bishop is b-17g for
okay queen afternoon okay I mean yeah
there's a few options
so we just go 8-4 or we develop the
bishop
like 57 in our vision d7
the one nice single vigilance here is a
defender who want to go defy first to
make some decisions sometimes like we
don't get run my little wolf I'll say
you want to go for od5 od5 first
nd 5b is 95
no but it has to be so good Bishop we
just need to pick a plan I'm very
flexible
it all looks good I don't know like a
good if d5 I'm only concerned about f5
happening so he takes well that's why I
like the bishop on to you so then if
somewhere and then trying to get f5
you
8:45 ticks context 95 enough to
how
how badly do you want to start
stop 'if I've what to think of a move
like Bishop e6 right huh 9066 Queen
takes c6 but three pieces fine but hmm
there should be five there should be
five work t6 Bishop you see if he found
them we have ninety five but it's messy
okay so that's too many that's her no
that's like so
we need to pick and go the two bits
couple of bits there from our producer
or that's a move that's showing no fear
in the position yeah
to me e5 sort of speaks for itself but
maybe now 595 would take d6 they take
with the bishop
well maybe we don't even take these six
week no you're right
if a 595 takes these six takes we can
even take with check and then play
queenie five if we want to force the
Queen's off the board
yeah or even a queen on d4 there
great night I feel like we should go eat
fired I like it 'if I've just let's
trust ourselves there's definitely no
huge risk by playing you fun I like the
end game though if I 595 take d6 twice
Queenie five if they trade so e5 is weak
and they do have this work age five move
to hit our a5 Punk into those variations
I kind of like putting our Queen on d4
though so we should instead with the
pawn here wait because you're talking on
the endgame right yeah I think of them
oh no no but Queen takes is interesting
no but I don't like the indium as much
something are committed upon to a4 we
don't game out a very important tempo
and none of the F files open we can play
great
we're being general but if Queen e5
takes takes Knight moves and we played
94 threatening the knight on c6 but they
have Knight a for Bishop e7 night of
four I'm worried about the long term
there where is it you just listen Dani
it feels like you could take on e5 95
left like Queen f3 rook F 1 and just
like oh yeah ok it's really a French
position of I've seen one I'm into this
for you oh yeah all right Queen f3
they have bishop you should be selling
the queen g4 there maybe and just get
out yeah kick queen chief for and then
we attended ideas of Knight c3 shut
though I'm kind of keeping an eye out on
it but I'm not afraid of it from beyond
okay let's do it because after my last
Queen T 4 is better cuz Queen d4
threatens 96 jackin some positions with
g7 that's awkward though if 24
we're also threatening to slide to Chi
for the queen of three has the more
concrete Frank we have also Queen before
they might be able to I don't know if
it's good at the castle but Queen of
three definitely stops on castings
Queenie tried just okay
also rubbing min on the clock this is a
tough game so he's not about this the
Queen's before are you well queen chief
or you also via the actual
Gigi I mean do we want to start with a 3
a 3 Rock f1 Ricca fade
you
you can almost make the case for no no
for what is the f5 no I was gonna castle
yeah I Kathleen I don't like I I don't
actually I I'm starting to see some
positions that I don't like like what
just like static positions so Rick I
fade be through and I'm like
I like some chances but another hand
will go you know if we don't meet them
after a cafe I see some positions where
a king position is like the asylum act
so so that's it III what you do queen c5
followed by maybe Bishop a 6-4 Bishop d7
Bishop a six
sorry salient it looks like 25 Bishop e6
give you all you want
mm-hmm are you gonna take I might run my
king is well rook e8 King to c7
kingi southern king see soon you're
slippery diamond one well I thought you
were marching eat the bras feels bad man
Michael no one's on our team
couple guys played for both teams though
the chat you know
nice to see the continued support
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the moments talking with dr. Warren see
I was just gonna say do you think that
they're kind of thought that art
[Music]
I don't know what they're gonna do now
I've no clue no but see now I wish
you're just subscribed hey what's up see
Nile or Easter I was a senile oyster
what's long story that's why I see I see
narrow disc e in the gym there it is
like we're channeling him
that's what I feel like right now I feel
like he would like metaphor I don't know
I just whenever I see these eight four
eight three ideas flimsy and I had a
game against head and Stein groups in
the Icelandic GM he's been a champion
and we had this sort of tension where he
tried for this a4 a3 stuff and I just
like okay you're not meeting and felt
good so okay if we take e6
takes Bishop g6 King moves is there a
win no that looks okay so moving up here
is 9h 532 Tate g7 but Knight c3 Chuck
you gotta watch out for oh but there's
still if takes takes Queen we take g7 he
moves the king there's no like win there
oh it's good
93 Chinese came to mind goes my Nike six
check we don't don't worry about 93
that's the good news the bad news is
well 96 of Bishop b5 check to follow
yeah Nike six check takes takes but do
we we when they can't play nice III
because it takes they can take with the
Queen and our Queens head no we have
Bishop b5 check and then we can trade
Queens oh nice nice fine nice fine 296
Bishop takes pawn takes Queen takes we
can only have what's our bailout if we
don't find anything ninety-five Bishop
takes Queen g4 or maybe queen g4 to
start does maybe we don't wanna make a
four to start threatens to take East ace
I give I'm getting more and more worried
about Knight to c3 but yeah but never
the thing is we always taking of King
you want so if Queen eight takes b2 then
we take on I want to get a six so badly
but I don't should we just go for an 86
that's in 96
okay well wait a sec wait a sec huh
takes a 93 yeah takes nice to do it up
there should be five minutes
yeah we should be fine
to
and can our witness take or do play
Quincy five I think we can take what do
you think first fin a voice change
that's occurred
here comes Lake we'd see five do you
want to fight Queen so I'm actually I'm
actually being me
what these guys are really coming at us
now
you want to take a b2
I was gonna play juicers uh sure I don't
know if they're threatening but we're
long time
it could get tricky they're gonna take
on each for maybe let me put 25 what do
you mean sure okay definitely like
definitely sounds like one of those for
the 9-1-1 prank calls
queenie five he should be
I can say that the last three minutes of
the game of this banana has been
impossible
here and I'm trying to support you along
no you're not gonna support me you're
trying to extort me I'm here for you and
you're laughing
I'm trying to check me I beat you
what's wrong with Queenie five let's fry
it
of 93
this is I don't know what to say
we have ideas we can take on me too
yeah yeah I want to take a sheet you
should do five minutes before key for
take yo come on I'm working hard here
for sure
you go
or was your suggestion no wasn't as good
as this cuz I want to do 93 but she
takes it too
we just can't move anything
I am calculating is best I can but I
thought was good action is better what
see there was too risky
I liked your movie we have 24 and Queen
f6 coming oh man they don't even see a
move here oh me too Queen takes me to
just take a beat you like to get a
ticket it's really risky though oh we
have no three we've rookie 308 Queen
Dana Brooke 83 no no okay three just
take it okay now go Brooke there's no
mate
wait rook da egg takes takes we have
nice e63 Brooke III rookie three oh my
gosh Willie at five seconds I missed
that
oh my gosh play Brooke c3 pin the bishop
okay that's good move - oh my god I
forgot really up five seconds take it
take the Queen okay good that's even
better
your your baller right now no no plate
okay thanks the bishop was hanging for
free oh crap 95 spent ninety five oh my
god I blew it the bishop was just
hanging oh okay mid time good time hey
for what no rookie semester the must be
daddy with
hang on king e7 right yes
Dani has the most let's take another
famous Nick meeting one free bishop
clean it well you have to candy six rock
f7 uh-huh
so what we gotta go King there 97 yeah
we get counterplay whoo
fancy
do you want to go e5
do think we can beat them down a few
bombs probably its Bishop f1 also maybe
you want to go fish bath one yeah King
goes team Walter yet it's age 43
Oh looks like he could move that damn it
Robert
you
a monitoring time trouble let's cut the
King off play route t6 1804 hope you can
appreciate that
unrespected me cannot force him don't
know put the knife came up sixteen five
Canyon Oh ain't gonna go to h4 because
the girls have to yeah I like what are
you thinking
[Music]
or a six
okay her after me before
[Music]
you
we push that epon yep c5 when were
threatening rookie six yeah I mean we
owe that pawn is so whatever DS which we
can weed out a lot of time alright next
e4 late 94
we gotta go get that pawn 96 rip d6 rook
maybe sneak some we're running out of
time dude yeah you made a good move I
like it Bishop 6 95 95
if he was 55 my plan keen to be 5 and c6
bushing plate for first wanted me to
give him the ball he pushes they can't
move
Oh King afore I forgot about that what
about just night g9g for just yeah I
know g4 safe square it's fine their King
can't get anywhere like they're just
running around in circles but you need
to move point three seconds or a five I
guess you have to or 93 we're good - I
like yeah let's just repeat for a second
king c3 normal kc 4 yeah yeah oh be fine
now rook b5 King Defour in the 95 let's
go to a rook a to and keep the outside
Passport
ok let's do it and just bring the King
now closer
it's getting if in King before take
definitely kick three O king c4 King I
think you supposed to live
yeah like king c4 keep our king
attacking it's a useful piece because we
have III totally cover
and like your work have to check before
okay like that is their king going to be
six next oh my god Danny I love this
I think oh the bishop eight we can just
push the a pond right yeah just go a six
wait what okay they try to trick us they
trying to trick us
no no no the name overlooked see a check
so they're trying to trick us it's what
if we go look a three check because they
can't sing g2 without very nice that's
oh wait wait drew g3 g3 III get about
taking that King back yes so they try to
trick us and then a6 they walked right
into a trip okay six
you
this feels like a worst version maybe
you can try proof d3
you
per kg my
my dev - and then Brooke Effie Jason
Moran
I'm not sure this is a verse written in
sense
like yeah should they can go to h5 here
yeah
it's funny it's pretty strong that's
what I mean so the question is is Rick
f3 a move I think I broke up three days
very much move but then you can take two
and sorry what
no thank you yeah no it's not I mean you
have to go to King right 94
you
[Music]
I have a funny feeling
we're getting somewhere guess you want
to leave the rook on e7 that's what King
on g4 yeah
you
guess that's
can you forgive her
right native three is gonna do
should you just put the e75 checks a
great keep their King out
yeah well work if I check will win de
pon - in some positions Wow this has
been intense
okay five rapini three both hum I liked
okay five and they like a five right
yeah why not
I think my judgments at so q3 I like it
it's blockade nights are so good in
these type of situations worth reading
g4 9 h 3 9 f 4g 500 push them baby right
lately wait wait - is watch out workout
3 coming what do we do
Knight g4 maybe just one g4 take a punch
of scoreboard I think if we go 3 it's
nothing
we're just background yep oh but they've
III I forgot about that cuz the bishop
still protects the dangler up yeah but
we have 93 and the pawn on e3 is gonna
be targeted so go negative 91 yeah and I
do you want bring the knight back to you
yeah yeah keep the dark square block
hate alive yeah because the book was
also challenging us
hello that we've dominated the rook
tonight III presumably they're gonna
give it a check but we don't care
yeah should we go to d2 now and then run
this d 2r f - g 2r f - I think D - makes
don't use better yeah but because if you
would have before they broke up free
checking yeah yeah yeah
so King C 3 nub I'll be sure yeah I feel
pretty sure okay here we go
King before you give run back around to
F for King even a of kin G 500 that's
tricky so then King see yeah baby hmm
there's got to be like a knight C for
trick or a Knight d5 they go Kings you
know that doesn't work
I remember that other Bishop to King b5
I think you let us hear to do it but
could we if we go 95 right they take 95
95 they can't take us then we had a
queen oh I think we have to go for this
at this point we're kind of POD
committed now can we take their pawn on
e4 if we take on chief I think we can
how cyclic Duffy
oh my god I think we can because I was
it's a nice season but I think you just
take their pawn first and you take it
definitely take the pond and we can move
our King away and then go back for the
bishop this is winning we may have
gotten so lucky with that I and then we
made like a million mistakes good god I
think that we just walked into that King
e4 idea what it's funny ice of a king he
5 yeah definitely we don't 1 our piece
now we're threatening Knight b6 all
right so Knight B doesn't matter maybe
six looks good okay doing it but we have
to be careful not to need someone get
this Bishop I don't know how we're gonna
do that
so night c4 he's gonna more a knight
around I don't know I really don't know
goose t4 and then Knight to d6 hold this
do you want to try to keep the king cut
off with lyric b5 next
[Music]
go work that's fine it's fine rook rook
to d1 oh you can go to a a right in
rookie 7
I prefer the rook behind I think I
prefer the roof behind and then you can
like throw the bishop all the way down
is that a draw my Kings cut up he can he
can walk
oh you just bloody rook but it looked
scary getting checked in open mic Engler
oh my god let's go Game five baby
we're so Eric's voice changed so it's
really deep and the last five minutes of
the game he sounds like bean and we I
basically was laughing I couldn't focus
it's an eric had to just play and yeah
basically our whole geek is brewed from
that oh my gosh
Danny I think I think you just play the
best game
oh my gosh well I know we want to start
Game five but we got to get one breaking
I gotta go pee I've been like lemon
fidget I've been fidgeting for like ten
minutes uh apparently I went through a
voice change no but listen we're gonna
take a very quick break guys and I'll be
right back here we go
we're coming back
[Music]
oh my gosh it continues Benny stop
playing good chess hey that was amazing
stop you stop it
dude when we saw that we could take the
d5 pawn and then take it and then or
take efore and walk into the pin we got
so lucky we were like oh we could take
you for it worked out so here we go I
don't know what we're doing next but
what five three three oh my gosh it's
gonna be nerve wracking and we're gonna
flag immediately we can't do three check
can't we are we it's three check oh my
gosh
president championship it's three check
all right Danny what are you wanting to
start out with okay look I know what MBO
would you so then do it trust your
Maxine you know he lost today to moment
Jorah trust the inner Maxine yeah three
choices literally you can lose in like a
freaking second yep
so Maxine place this way okay I like it
I mean they're gonna if they don't have
experience they'll try go 90
that because you don't want to give too
much material just like king of the hell
okay
so what knight c6 now presume layer or
a6 actually and just stop some a6 it
stop some shenanigans their best move
can they hear us their best move is a5
thief okay so what do you want to do
okay this is a good line musica yeah
each Knight g5 knowledge 3
we can also beat them in chassis
come on the page five what is this it's
rabbit but yeah probably
it's I think h4 is strong for bottle no
like if we don't place three I guess
we're gonna go G for are you over here
uh I'm generally concerned just cuz I
don't know anything about soap and nuts
opening this variant but the position
doesn't
t4 do you ever want to quit before
looking already just takes in 96
yes Queen III
issues like I can just say the one they
can't convert it over
it's a big 23 rate also quickly I'm
saying we can't put that one check but
if there's anything no more than that's
like a difference
what a castle let's castle on a g6 right
yep day you wonder why I was so
aggressive last game why is I watched
Shambhala of clay at the US senior and
he okay so here do we go Bishop d6 or do
we go no I think we do for sure which
isn't a bad move into position anyway
Queen c7 he rode but how do you want to
do with this check on h2 we're gonna do
it now do another
then do you sacrifice that that piece or
never I want to take on chief or then
play h3 what about Knight e5 here yeah
that's exactly what I was gonna suggest
cuz that's that's what I wanted cuz they
might have been taking on f4 so my dad
which is hey one thing if they take we
take with the night were threatening
Knight f3 and Bishop h2 check that's to
next but do we take within their the
mission I think tonight okay I like it
any because they're just walking into
opening and King we can play Knight
takes e4 and H 3 o 4 runs in two runs in
two but then f3 is an option at least oh
my goodness okay so we're not giving up
any checks
then just play well
it's so hard for me to determine the
value of a check what's the best time
you see it that you're most concerned
about like objectively the best like d4
is the best sorry unless you mean that
f3 teenage one
I meant Knight f3 takes bishop h2 King
h1
I agree with you completely come on okay
we can play Knight f3 we can also just
play 90's g4 oh wait a second
like what if we take on g4 and go h3 one
thing I knew about
it's very very tricky for them okay
let's though this is a grim menopause
rub 45 seconds a night f3 Bishop f3 whoa
we just got another huge cheer may pro
may pro thank you I think Knight takes
e4 is good because it threatens bishop
itch too and then Knight takes F - sorry
bishop where Knight takes e4 threatens
Bishop H - I know but it's not a bishop
H live in 94 where they got a 5
three less looking h1 and
and we'll go from there thank you so
much Matt bro
yeah they don't have a good following
actually dr. King is one no key
you
come on
come on can you hear me
hello
talk to me
parley how here you know you hear my
hurry
yeah yeah you you disconnected I heard
you the whole time Oh
yeah u5 it's my first instincts
but
I'm just not smart because Age 3 is only
just one shark it's actually two checks
is the Queen Cleo -
King is one and then
we know six at the right moment maybe
start with Queen okay they went there
so we can take with the bishop and then
take back with the night we can also
just play Bishop e7 or Bishop e7 then
they take on you think what I'm getting
kind of work I know but we get H 3 and H
2 I don't know yeah I hear you if we
take twice and take on e5 with the
bishop at the end
I mean we're in decent shape I guess if
they play f4 the thing is neither side
just got the check it's right what Riza
we've gotten less than we bargained but
maybe night 65 is I don't I kind of like
having pieces rather than pawns I mean
you really want to check somewhere
that's why I like Bishop takes pawn
takes Knight takes at f4 now no that's
bad actually
so where do we go Bishop c7 and just
kind of way to move you know night off
Bishop's so you take e5 twice F for
Bishop c7 know I'm seeing mr. seven now
they're gonna make 894 now then one
night of four I think shoots if Bishop
c7 they takes you four will get h3 right
that's kind of harsh for them but Bishop
on get to h2 or what if we think that
such gonna steal our King and then if
sure we should let that pawn what inch
do if we think it's going to show their
king we think of Bishop e7
[Music]
we can just do nothing as well we could
do nothing we could put it out for you
I don't like that for okay we take that
right yeah what do you want to go you
looked at for are you okay with this Oh
mom which one do you want fish about for
king h1
honestly honestly King which one seems
pretty sexy
for some reason for some reason first
let's say he plays g5 then f4 or
something yeah yeah it is cooking each
one
you
so rupee eight or something like that
yeah Brooke being then B 5 and then B
seven yeah
we've got to get rid of that bishop
around that king and then there's an F
for matter you played Bishop f6 and just
dangle Queen c7 b4 b5 first number
should be seven kind of thing
we have to watch out for our King safety
as well
the f4 bishop somewhere f5
able to play Bishop f6 and after FIV
castle I'm just saying we're happy to
trade Queens even though for Bishop 6 f
5b v they take we take with the F phone
they're still going 10s
I just want we lost somebody
let me Luis come on
apparently in a month no an Eriksen is
playing right yep can they hear us too
right now who can they hear just Eric
oh that's like just like before it's I'm
sure he can still talk to him via voice
but we just lost his family
ah bishop c7 and then f5 they look scary
man maybe Bishop cf6 never d5 ago
f5 of a d5 no then this Quinn it for I
need Bishop six and Castle kingside
think I'm alone out here guy
you
whereas a mom
come on is that you are you back but I I
guess I don't know I could hear you the
whole time it's just like so weird I'm
trying to fight for us buddy
we got a piece up or our checks are
coming the position is totally winning I
mean there's not getting a check from
off the piece you want to take on e6 yes
and then go fish before well d5 is
hanging as well if he doesn't take the
pond okay this before we take on
that for
you
Queens before none
so
just mr. Shakti Bishop g5 here a stiff
Queenie's now we're dead
Bishop takes d5 and we can resign
yep I know joy okay
yeah and I think c4 was the move that
did uh Sam I think
maybe the whole thing wasn't so good
though no but NATO three check we got
two checks in
they would have played king h1 but then
we didn't give him any material yeah
this is dead
that was a fairly easy game actually I
stopped being scared after King each one
that was an obnoxious way to end this
match after great chess we go to a silly
three check game bonds we'll play basket
of three you guys played King h1 I know
that's what we thought too but we're bad
if Knight of three King h1 like what do
we do next
just oh that's what we thought but we
didn't know what you what nobody need
you tonight f3 if they go King H warm
either Knight h2 or something just like
but then II 5 in 1971 then that takes
before or night takes up 1 Hess's right
block 94 I prefer 94 the native one look
what you guys gave us was what would
that what the community gave us was way
more money than we ever asked for
yeah no people have been donating like
crazy and it's I mean that's a foot just
connect it there and I felt like Eric
could just handle it one on two d the
Native American elder community is gonna
be very happy adopt adopt and elder that
what we just did that's right that's
right it's what you did oh my gosh that
was that was a that was a frustrating
way to end it three check is is like
it's just so hard
thanks for your donation if you win
tonight if reject know if we would have
had it I don't know we had it man their
voices are ridiculous I don't want to
end the stream because at this point
everyone's just enjoying the cheers it's
like I shut off the cameras right now
I got Eric good like I got a coyote's
Danny we played such a good game in that
chest man man oh man I I have to say
though but one thing that was surprised
me was that you guys repeated the
Sicilian line because I I thought that
both times the position is very good for
black
really want the Sawyer
but obviously since you guys were
repeating it we also thought that you
must have thought that was very good for
white so I knew that someone was very
good I don't know if we thought it was
very good I thought it was just a game
yeah yeah and then as I stated Danny I
went full Shabalala because I was just
in the comments here at the US and he
played so many crazy hectic games as I
all right moves like you know Brooke
Gage from f1 Queen 84 Knight f4 all the
stuff fell for those Danny just getting
a bit gradient but the cheval the mix
yeah
shavon Scarb you switch roles here Hess
was more aggressive throughout the night
I played a good end game once we reached
it was not it was not our normal roles
today but Danny that's actually been the
the theme of these matches do you
remember last match
there was also very nice and the first
game where you guys beat us was also a
super nice in-game yeah I don't know you
guys you guys bringing out good chest
right now I'm just frustrated but how
this three chicken woman it was my fault
we didn't play that f3 so you know but
it stuck so what Bill I don't know like
Robert Knight f3 King H one day each to
rook e1 rook e1 Knight takes d4 pawn
takes g4 I'm also kind of aged through
we just knew it no you get a check your
data check they don't get h3 me please
it's not clear to me that the fact that
the piece but and get no checks I
thought it was just over them right you
know I guess I didn't um and it has made
a great point which was that it was
really dumb because the moment we gave
you guys more minors it was just silly I
mean you can't give you can't give more
minors right in a three check game
because pawns cos pawns don't check very
fast so anyway this was a blast though
honestly like regardless of the of
the match result I mean this is like
some of our most fun shows I don't know
how you guys feel but this is no it's
like not even why I'd even close these
are so much fun
no they're a lot of fun and apparently
the people love them even Darryl's here
right he might be a fan of settling it
by basketball I'm sure Houston maybe the
two of us yeah two of us paired with an
NBA player for charity and we'll do it
at the Rockets training facility each of
us get up get a member of the Rockets on
our team I recall we called Westbrook
actually Harden you just called two
players things anyway you guys are
awesome seriously guys Eric is silly you
got a lot what am I saying
oh let's remind everybody while you're
here we got some upcoming events in fact
all of us right now have been we've been
friend of Me's I don't like to say
enemies but we're all about to join
sides and do a lot of commentary for the
GCT coming up as well as the single as
well as the single cup and so uh we've
got it we've got a lot on the plate and
we got the Isle of Man just looming over
there the green swiss so anyway make
sure you mark your calendars if you
didn't know Amon and I I think we'll
have one of the calls first for the
grand chess tours rapid and blitz but I
don't remember the schedule but I think
you and I are Celina July 27th yeah on
Saturday so Amon and I will be together
on July 27th for the first round of the
Paris rapid and blitz and then the 28th
we have the Jesse C um me and Hess and
and then it all just continues to roll
so once again you guys get the better I
have no choice
we're not worthy I bowed down I guess I
have to go wait so um on I gotta go do a
video yeah they don't know that if
people don't know this Yeah right that's
right I'm so glad because yeah so we we
made a little off-camera side bet and I
think that if we lost Eric had to wear
his famous bowtie from from the famous
image during his nest many
shows but I said that if Danny lost or
if rather teams has to calm loss that
Danny's punishment would be he had to
watch first of all watch my hair
tutorial videos on our YouTube channel
and he had to then use the tips from the
video and apply it to his own hair
it's gonna happen to you guys to see on
stream so I'm looking forward to that I
don't know but you guys I am alright
guys you guys this was a blast
Robert take a deep breath buddy I know I
you know hey you didn't know Danny
well you know what he do we just
struggles it's okay
they play great it was a great match we
lost in a single game of three check it
was a great match so hey we'll get we'll
get it again oh and two it will be like
the Red Sox to their Yankees in the 90s
where there's a rivalry even if they're
up like 15 to nothing Red Sox
so eventually we'll get a win alright
anyway thank you everybody for being
here guys seriously the community can we
all just say down that was you guys just
took home a lot more cash than you
signed up for this is awesome
sixteen hundred dollars from the
community so that's crazy it's awesome
thank you that goes into the prize fund
I don't remember how and then it goes
into charity and anyway we'll figure it
out but thank you everybody
all the good places all right guys enjoy
the night Robert go get yourself some
Chinese food buddy
it's 11:30 here in the East Coast and a
lot of people I appreciate that I was a
lot of fun I mean Danny I you're hard to
get for me yeah that's true that's right
I got you gotta get going buddy alright
thank you babe thank you all the donors
Darryl may prolong there were so many of
you guys let's see I'm on fire everybody
everybody donate it you guys are amazing
I'm just looking at the chat right now
besides Tommy
we're not thanking you buddy all right
Steve